>> Ladies and gentlemen, will
you please take your seats as
the keynote session is about to
commence.  Thank you.
>> Good morning, everyone. I'm
Jason, and I lead the developer
product group at Google.  I'm so
excited to be here with all of
you at Google Developer Days,
Europe.  This region is an
amazing one for technology.
Startup hubs blossoming across
the continent from London to
Paris to Berlin and Warsaw, the
talent here is incredible.
In fact, a few years ago, when I
was a CEO at
Shazan in London, we would hire
across the  continent.  Some of
the best developers came from
Germany and Greece and Lithuania
and Poland.  And fast forward
to today, Europe has more
developers than the United
States and Canada combined.
[ Applause ]
Which is why it's really
exciting to have Google
Developer Days here so that we
can meet and work with all of
you.  We want to give you what
you need to turn your ideas into
reality.  Whether you're
building a mobile app or using
new  technologies like AR and
machine learning.  We want to
enable you to focus on the
problems you're trying to solve
and minimize the pain points of
building a product.
And in addition to building
products to help you succeed,
we're also working on building
out trainings to deepen your
technical capabilities year
round.  Today I'm happy to share
that we've opened our mobile
web certification that will
enable you to further expand
your web skills.  And on the
ground, our team is working in
over 130 countries.  And within
Europe, we've reached over
185,000 developers just this
year through local events and
programs.  We have, in Europe,
over 200 developer experts, many
of whom are in this room today,
who are sharing their expertise
and are continuing to expand
the developer ecosystem through
programs such as women tech
makers, the Google Development
Agency program, and our Google
Development Groups.  Last year
we started our Launchpad
accelerator program and brings
them to Silicon Valley to meet
with leads.  In our class, the
first startup from Poland.
These three entrepreneurs saw
the need to provide therapy at
scale for autistic children.
In respondent, they created Dr.
Omnibus, for children with
special education needs.
Allowing children to learn
behavior patterns and responses
to real-life scenarios, and
their teachers and therapists
can review their progress.
The best part is that students
can play these games on their
own, allowing them to get
therapy every day rather than
once a week, which makes an
incredible impact long-term.
This is just one of many stories
how the Europe development
community is making a big
impact.
Now, I'd like to bring up some
of my colleagues to share
updates across our developer
platforms.  And let's start with
how we're making the Android
development process easier.
Please welcome D
DAN: Right.  Thank you, Jason.
It is the best time ever to be
an Android developer.  Now, I
have been developing for Android
for almost nine years and spent
seven of those years at Google.
But I have never seen anything
like what we have now.  An
incredible confluence of
meaningful developer  changes.
We're seeing ever more powerful
tooling.  A clear path forward
for app design.  A new
programming language and
fundamental improvements to the
distribution model.  And many of
this change derives from
listening to all of you in the
developer community.
And all of this is happening
amidst the incredible momentum
that Android continues to have.
I mean, we're seeing 2 billion
active devices on Android and 82
billion apps installed from
Play.  And what is even more
amazing is how this momentum is
making so many developers
successful.  The number of
developers are over a million
installs grew 35% in the past
year.  Now, to leverage this
distribution to build great
businesses, we expanded direct
carrier building to reach 900
million devices with over 140
million operators.  And the
number of people buying on Play
grew by almost 30% this past
year.
That's not enough.  We know we
can make distribution even
better by removing the friction
from app installs and making the
entire experience more dynamic.
So instant apps is one of the
big bets in bringing users to
your apps and our early adopters
are seeing it.  And they saw
that sharing content increased
55% in their instant app.  And
Vimeo increased session
durations by 130%.  Jet found
that the conversion rate in
their shopping app increased by
27% and there are many many
stories like these.
At I/O we opened up Android
instant apps to all Android
developers.  Which means anyone
can now build and publish an
instant app.  Since then we have
made instant apps available to
more than 500 million across
countries where Google operates.
And we organize the product
into feature modules and use the
code in the instant app and
your installable  app.  We're
easying the process of
refactoring your app into the
feature modules by using the new
module
modulear vise Android studio.
And we have space saving shares
libraries and asset deliver to
on the wire compression.  When
you're ready, upload the instant
app APK with the installable in
the console.  Visit g.co/
instant/apps.  Since you are
here, you heard the exciting
news from I/O.  We're now
offering first class support for
the Kotlin in Android.  And
Kotlin support is now built into
Android Studio.  So --
[ Applause ]
So, you know, obviously I don't
have to tell you this, why
Kotlin?  And that's because the
community really wanted it.
Kotlin is a mature production-
ready language that's been
around for five years.  And so
we investigated.  And people
that were investigating became
Kotlin champions.  As developers
, languages are the tools that
we use to express our thoughts.
And with Kotlin, there's so
much less noise between what I
want to say and how I say it.
And since our announcement at
Google I/O, it's been growing
like crazy.  It's great to see
so many of you adopting it.  But
to be here, we have added
Kotlin as an additional program.
We're not replaces the Java
programming language or C++, and
we support as much Kotlin as
you want.  From 0 to  100%.  It
operates 100% with the Java
language.  That means you can
keep every line of code and
seamlessly call from Kotlin into
the Java programming language
and back and you can start with
as little as a single Kotlin
class.  And partnering,
we are here and giving a talk
on Kotlin today.  Please swing
by to learn more if you haven't
already.
Now, minimizing install friction
with instant apps and support
of the common programming
language are two of the ways we
have listened to your  feedback.
You want faster, easier
development with better tools
and libraries.  So Android
Studio, our official IDE,
purpose-built for Android, and
we keep increasing our
investment.  We focused on speed
and smarts and platform support
and new libraries for
architecture.  And this is going
to migrate to stable release --
soon.  And you can see the
speed and smarts updates we have
made to Android Studio behind
me.  But one thing in particular
, your  feedback made driving
down sync and build time our
number one priority.
Benchmarking with a real-life,
hundred module since 2.2, build
time dropped from 3 minutes to 2
seconds.  We're continuing to
build on performance.  And for
me, super-exciting, for the
emulators, we added the Play
store for end to end testing.
And now platform support.  We
released the latest dessert name
for Android.  You'll find
Android Oreo, system images,
improved files.  And a download
dependencies, you don't have to
go to the  SDK manager anymore.
We are now distributing
through our repository.  And
making them easier.  Providing a
guide for best practices and
life  cycles.  We launched a
preview of new architecture
components.  Libraries and
common tasks, a  ViewModel, data
storage, life cycle management.
And soon, announcing support
for paging, making it  easier to
use recycler view.  App quality
-- yeah.  Very excited about
that.
So app quality is an essential
piece to growing a business.
And we took apps and analyzed
app quality and business
success.  When apps move from
average to good quality, we see
a six fold speed increase and
spend, and a seven fold increase
in retention.  Quality is
queen.  Now, your app quality
might differ depending on the
type of device it's running on.
So to make sure the targeting
devices working best for your
app, you can target specific
devices in the Play console.
Yeah.  It's awesome.  Been
waiting for that forever.
You can browse a detailed device
catalog.  If you need a certain
amount of RAM, have specific
system on system shift, you can
set target rules.  And you can
see your installs, ratings and
revenue details per device.
Now, we've got Android Vitals in
the dash console.  You can
pinpoint common issues like
excessive crash rates, frozen
frames, slow  rendering,
excessive wakeups and more.
These are enhanced by improved
profilers in Android Studio and
new instrumentation in the
platform.  Speaking of the
platform, Android I/O adds so
much for the developers.  Such
as vastly improved font support,
notification channels, a new
native AI.  Massive improvements
in the run time, including a
series of optimizations to make
your apps run smoother.
Adaptive icons and harden
security with Google Play now
enabled on every device with
Google Play.  Improved
accessibility, wide color, and
extra long screens.  And I'll be
diving into all of this and
much many in detail later today.
But let's talk about some of
the ways we're extending the
Android platform.
Last week we announced and
launched AR Core.  Now --
[ Applause ]
ARCore is a platform for build
ing augmented reality apps on
Android and uses three key
technologies to integrate
virtual content with the real
world as seen through the camera
.  Motion  tracking so the phone
can track its position relative
to the world.  Environment it
will understanding, allows it to
see the ground or coffee table.
And light estimation allows
the phone to estimate the
current lighting conditions.
Now, this is being offered as an
early preview.  You can
experiment with and build new AR
experiences.  And this is an
opportunity for you to get
feedback on an early version of
the API.  And this preview is
the first step in a journey to
enabling AR capabilities across
the entire Android ecosystem.
Check out the documentation
pages to learn more.
All right.  Switch gears.
Literally.  Android  Auto.  It's
early days, but incredible
growth.  We have increased the
number of Android cars to over
50 car brands.  And there are
over 300 compatible
models today.  It's triple
from a year ago.  And it's
becoming a standard feature in
every car.  And we have made it
available with a stand alone
phone app, opening up the
platform and ecosystem to
millions are of drivers no
matter the car they're driving.
With WhatsApp and Aloe, or the
latest Apple releases, we have
great apps.  It's growing
rapidly, but this is just the
beginning.  We're working with
two European partners, Audi and
Volvo on systems powered by
Android and we're excited to
partner with them to usher in
the future of  connective cars.
Now, voice input is critical
for safety reasons.  And the
Google system can have the voice
as we move from a mobile first
world to an AI first world.  And
we want to be the best
copilots.  Your assistant can
talk about traffic, show gas
stations, play your favorite
song.  And many of these
experiences are only possible
because developers like you are
developing the right APIs.
Thank you.
Now to the living room.  Android
TV has seen amazing device
growth.  Strong partnerships
with pay TV operators and others
allowed us to double the number
of activated devices in 2016.
We expect that trend to continue
and further increase.  We are
seeing this across the set top
box and in the smart TV form
factors, including the many
European solutions powered by
Android TV.  And expanded our
international footprint to more
than 70 countries and more than
3,000 apps in the Play store.
And the way we redefine the
experience.  This is channel
Based and content first.
Divided into channel rows, each
created by a media app to
display a window of content
relevant to you.  And selecting
program takes you in.  You need
to finish binge watching.  And
what is relevant to you.  And
you can easily transition media
apps from other Android devices.
And we have made big updates
to the library, such as the
playback element, allowing
detailed seek thumbnails.  And,
of course,  integrated the
Google Assistant.  Allows you to
search, launch video content,
and then dim the lights when you
want to watch, all using your
voice.
All right.  Let's switch to
something a little bit closer.
Android Wear.  During the
holiday period last year,
Android Wear saw 72% growth.
And that was before we launched
Android Wear 2.0.  The number of
brands supporting it doubled
from 12 to  24.  And the choice
of Android Wear watches doubled
from 23 last year to 46.  And
it's enabling fashionable
watches, such as the connected
modular, and the Louis Vitton.
And partners across many price
points and brands.  And apps are
taking advantage of Android
Wear 2.0 and the stand alone
functionality.  This app from
our partner, telegram, you're
connected to an Android or
iPhone, or without a phone at
all.  And it's never been
easier.  Another feature to
Android Wear 2 opinions 0,
allows watch faces to look at
extra information without
needing code.  Select the watch
faces they want with the most
important information they care
about, available at a glance.
Here the financial investment
app is showing your
overall portfolio value.  You
can tap on individual stocks to
see their values.  Finally, as
part of the launch, we announced
that the Google Assistant is
now on your
wrist.  Going forward, apart,
you will have another option to
bring a service to Android Wear
for  options for Google on Wear.
And we're excited about the
new capabilities.
All right.  With so many ways
for people to interact with
Android, the strong community,
the improvements in the
platform, tooling, and language
and distribution of Google Play,
it really is the best time ever
to be an Android developer.
Please, check out the sessions,
the trainings and the code labs
to learn how we're helping
developers make Android great.
Now, all of the Android form
factors are tapping into the
pour are tapping into the
Google Assistant.  And welcome
to the stage Tilke to talk about
what it means to developers.
Thank you.
>> Thanks, Dan. Hi, everyone.
As you just heard, the Google
Assistant is now available
across many device.  From your
phone to your car, to your watch
and TV.  It is also available
on Google Home, and all the
devices powered by the Google
Assistant SDK.  Tomorrow you'll
here more about these from my
colleague, Beshad who will talk
about the improvements on the
devices.  But today I want to
focus on what you -- as
developers -- can do to bring
the
power of the Assistant to your
own apps.  With the Assistant
across devices, you can grow
your user base in a new way.
But more importantly, you can
build apps for entirely new
assistive use cases.  Things
that were
previously not suited for the
voice-only interface of Google
Home.  Like shopping for
clothes.  Or ordering food from
a lengthy menu.  With UI
elements like image carousels,
lists and suggestion chips,
users can see more details.
They can also  seamlessly
transition between voice,
typing, or taps in a single
conversation to easily get
things done with your app.
We also want to make -- help you
grow your business by making it
easy to make purchases through
the Google Assistant.  We
designed the transactions
experience to be easy and
lightweight for users and
developers alike.  For payments
-- available in Europe soon --
you can choose Google-
facilitated
payments.  And they're easy to
integrate and use cards that
users stored with Google for
free.  Or use a payment method
that they have provided you.
You can use seamless account
linking to enable users to sign
into an existing account.  Or
create a new account with just
two taps.
But a transaction isn't over
when the user  pays.  The users
may want to check on, modify, or
reorder an item, which they can
do from the transaction history
view accessible in the Google
Assistant.  Finally, we built a
new order updates feature that
we're currently testing in the
U.S. to make it easier for the
users to reengage with your app.
You can send status updates
asynchronously, like when a car
arrives to pick them up or food
is delivered.  But none of this
matters it people can't discover
your app.  At I/O, we rolled
out a new app directory that
will
come to Europe along with the
Assistant.  Not only categories
and user ratings, it allows
users to try your app directly
from the directory page.  Users
can create a shortcut for your
app for an easy way to invoke
it.  For example, instead of
saying, okay, Google, ask
forecaster Joe what's the surf
report for the outer bank?  You
can just say, okay, Google, is
the surf up?  And to make
planning your app easier, the
Assistant is also learning from
the directory and from the
information provided by you --
the developer.  Thanks to these
signals, the assistant can often
respond to general requests
like, play a game, with a few
different options from third
parties.
Improving discovery is very
important for us.  So you can
expect ongoing investment and
improvements in this area.  It
is also important to us that the
developer process is smooth.
That's  why, at I/O, we launched
a new developer console.  The
actions console helps you work
as a team and collect data on
your app's usage, performance,
and user discovery patterns.  It
is integrated with the Firebase
and Google Cloud consoles to
share the data in your apps.  In
addition to the console, we are
providing access to developer
tools that allow you to quickly
and easily build apps for the
Assistant.  Since the launch of
our platform, we have worked
with an expanding number of
developer tool companies to make
their solutions compatible with
actions on Google.  We have
expanded the capabilities of
API,  API.AI, our conversation
building tool.  Launching new
features,
prebuilt agents and in-dialogue
analytics.  While we are still
in the early days of the
platform,
we are focused on making it more
robust and expanding its reach
and its capabilities.  We
recently launched in UK and
Australian English and will
launch the platform in French,
German, and other languages
following this year.
We're super-excited for the road
ahead and we want more of you
to join us by developing for the
platform.  With an addressable
audience of more than 100
million devices, new
capabilities like transactions
and an improved developer
experience, we think this is an
incredible opportunity for all
of us.  Now, the magic of the
Assistant is enabled by Google's
deep investment in AI and the
cloud.  So to tell you more
about how you can use it
directly, please welcome Sara.
[ Applause ]
SARA: Thanks,
Tilke.  I'm incredibly excited
to tell you about machine
learning.  I'm Sara Robinson on
the Google Cloud platform team
focused on big data and machine
learning.  Any time we see ML on
a slide, it gets a lot of
people's attention.  But before
diving into the details, I want
to talk about what machine
learning actually is.  At a high
level, machine learning
involves teaching computers to
recognize patterns in the same
way that our brains do.  Over
time, as machine learning models
are given more examples and
experience, they can improve and
start to generalize on examples
that they haven't seen before.
With more data, they're able to
generate better predictions.
Does anybody remember how they
learned their first language?
Your parents didn't give you a
dictionary and a bunch of
grammar books, that would be
weird.  Instead, you learned
over time after being exposed to
examples.  So, for example,
since
you had pierogies for dinner,
you saw them on your plate, and
heard it, and next time you had
them for dinner, you said that's
a pierogi.  And that's how
machine learning works too.  To
summarize, machine learning is
loosely based on how the human
brain learns with mathematical
neurons that mimic the neurons
in our brain.  They take a
vector as input, transform those
values and output new values.
And machine learning models lets
you solve problems without
requiring you to have exactly
the solution.  And as I
mentioned before, with more and
more data, these systems are
able to generate better
predictions.
Now, many people see the term
"Machine  learning," and
immediately think it's something
solely for experts.  Take a
look back 60 years ago, this was
the case.  This is the first
neural network invented in 1957.
It was an electronic device
that demonstrated the ability to
identify shape.  Back then, if
you wanted to work on machine
learning, you needed access to
extensive academic and computing
resources.  Fast forward to
today.  At Google even just
since 2012 the number of
products using machine learning
has grown dramatically.  But at
Google, we don't think machine
learning should be just for
experts.  We want to put machine
learning into the hands of
every developer and data
scientist -- that's all of you
-- with a computer and a machine
learning problem they want to
solve.
On Google Cloud platform we have
two ways to help you integrate
ML into your own applications.
First, if you're new to machine
learning, we have six
pre-trained APIs to give you
access to machine learning
models with a single
REST API request.  And if you
want to build and train from
scratch, we have a variety of
tools to help you do that as
well.  Let's start with the pre-
trained APIs.  We have a growing
number of models that are
already trained and continuously
updated using Google's own
domain expertise and data sets.
For example, the speech APIs
allows developers to put speech
to text into their own
applications.  Similar to okay
Google.  I'm going to
talk about the APIs in detail
later on.  But I'm going to give
an example of one.  I'm going
with the vision API, let's
developers better understand
their images.  You can try out
all of our machine learning
APIs directly in the browser.
I can upload an image and see
what vision API  responds.
Click on this.
And I'm going to choose a selfie
from yesterday in Krakow.  It's
a little  silly.  See what the
vision API responds.  It
identifies landmarks.  Landmark
detection is one of the
features.  It knows the building
and able to identify Main
Market Square.  The face
detection identifies my face and
is also able to identify the
emotions, joy and surprise.  I
won't go over all of the
response types in the browser,
but you can try this out.  Go to
cloud.google.com/vision.
So you have seen the machine
learning APIs used across a
variety of industries to
accomplish common tasks like
classifying images, identifying
inappropriate content,
extracting subjects from a text
document and more.  But many
have use cases beyond these
common machine learning tasks.
If you want to build your own
data for custom tasks, we have
that as well.  We know data is
at the core of any machine
learning problem and you need a
foundation of good data to get
started.  So in order to help
you prepare your data, we have
tools to help invest, transform,
clean, and store your data on
Google Cloud Platform.  Once
your data is ready, you can
train, deploy, and serve your
models at scale on manage Google
infrastructure.
In addition to all of this, the
Google brain team has provided
an open source library called
TensorFlow.  From the beginning,
we wanted everybody to benefit.
It's an open source project on
GitHub.  It's phenomenal.  It's
the most popular project on
GitHub with over 60,000 GitHub
stars and contributions from
many companies, not just Google.
I want to show you TensorFlow
playground, a  visualization of
a neural network in a browser.
So the dataset is called double
spiral.  And the data could be
anything.  We're classifying it
into one of two categories.  Say
it's email data, either Spam or
not Spam
.   The orange dots, Spam, the
others, not Spam.  Say we have a
data point right here, we can
almost immediately classify that
as Spam, as an orange dot.  But
it's much more difficult to
teach a computer these
underlying patterns.  And before
we start training, our neural
network's predictions don't make
too much sense.  This is the
output or the
prediction of the network.  Most
orange dots are being
classified as blue.  So if we
start training, we can see that
our loss, or error, is
decreasing slowly and able to
identify complex patterns in the
dataset.  We look at each
individual neuron, we see
they're performing simple
classification tasks.  But
moving through the data, it's
slowly able to each complex
patterns.  And with more
training, we can see that it's
able to identify this
double-spiral pattern.  As we
went through training, our loss
decreased, the accuracy of our
model increased, and it's able
to classify almost all of the
points.  Check this out at
playground.tensorFlow.org.  And
in addition to being a powerful
framework, TensorFlow is
designed to run anywhere.  Not
only on the cloud ML emergency,
but in your own servers, own
data centers and on VMs and
other cloud providers and
compile them down to ARM code
and run them on mobile devices.
If you want to utilize Google's
infrastructure to ingest data,
train
your model and run predictions
at scale, we have cloud machine
learning engine.  To use it,
prepare your training data in
Google Cloud storage or big
query,y your TensorFlow code
locally, and use the AI to run
predictions on ML emergency.
And for tasks like training a
model, we support GPUs, allowing
you to significantly accelerate
your workloads.  You can go to
this to learn more about it.
There's one more thing to share
with you.  One thing that's true
at Google, great software
shines brightest with great
hardware underneath.  We
started are several years ago to
see what we could accomplish
with our own accelerators.  The
result was a tensor processing
unit, TPU, announced at Google
I/O.  It was built specifically
for machine learning and
tailored for TensorFlow.  We
have been running TPUs in our
data centers for more than a
year, and they deliver an order
of magnitude better performance
per watt for learning.  They are
in alpha.  You want to sign up,
cloud.google.com/TPU.  And
finally, if you remember just
one thing from this
presentation, remember that our
goal on Google cloud platform is
to democratize ML learning.
Not only to
those, but to developers and
data  scientists.  And now over
to Tal to talk about the latest
in mobile web.
TAL: Thanks, Sara.  Hi,
everyone.  My name is Tal from
the Chrome team and I'm expected
to tell you about some of the
great improvements on the web.
The web is big.  With over 2
billion instances of Chrome, we
know that the web has tremendous
reach.  But one of the true
strengths of the web is that
it's bigger than a single
browser.  So regardless of
whether it's a laptop or a
desktop or a phone, they all
have a browser.  So any
web-based experience is
available on these billions of
devices today.  And we have seen
this have a real impact on how
many users web apps are reaching
.
We've all seen how quickly
mobile has been  growing.  And
native apps have been growing at
an incredible pace with it.
But what's really remarkable is
that even with the web's large
initial reach, we have seen the
average monthly web audience
growing even faster.  And
because of this growth, we're
seeing the web expand into new
areas with experiences like web
VR being built on the web
platform.  And the web continues
to pop up in more and more
places.  Even some you might not
expect.  We now see the web
popping up on watches, TVs, or
even fridges.
So with the web pretty much
everywhere, we're constantly
trying to push the boundaries on
what it can actually do.  Over
the past yearing with we've
shipped hundreds of additional
APIs that cover a range of
capabilities.  From making it
easy to integrate payments into
your web experience, to  making
it possible to build fully-
capable offline media
experiences directly on the web.
And with all of these new
experiences, we've seen a
massive growth in experiences
built on the web.  Accelerated
mobile pages -- or AMP -- allows
publishers to easily create
fast articles.  And since
launch, we've seen this grow to
over 2 billion AMP pages across
900,000 domains.  And beyond AMP
pages, the modern mobile web
also allows developers to build
rich, mobile experiences with
something that we call
progressive web apps, or PWAs.
PWAs are about helping web
developers leverage the web's
reach with now capabilities to
build high-class, immersive
experiences.  They can load
quickly.  They work offline.
And they can even send
notifications to users.  And
we've seen a number of amazing
experiences taking advantage of
these new  capabilities.  As
just one example, Twitter
recently launched a new web
experience.  Here they have a
polished, fast, immersive
experience that work on any
connection and can send users
notifications.  And since it's
built
completely on the web platform,
it's already accessible on
billions of devices.
And with an immersive experience
like this, we want to make sure
that it's really easy for users
to get back to it.  The home
screen has existed for some time
and allows you to add any
experience to their Android home
screen.  But with the improved
add to home screen flow, when
you add a PWA to the home
screen, it's fully integrated
into the  platform.  To users
it's like any other app
experience.  It will appear in
the app launcher and in
settings.  But since it's a PWA,
it's small.  Users can get an
immersive experience without
additional storage space.  And
with this improved experience,
it's available now.  With all of
these new capabilities, we've
also been working to make sure
that it's super-easy for web
developers to build these
experiences.  We'll be going
into a lot more detail about
PWAs throughout the web track
over the next two days.  But no
matter how you're  building your
web app, lighthouse is a tool
to help you.  Lighthouse is a
Chrome extension
tool to audit your site to
identify how to improve
performance, accessibility, and
progressive web appiness.  And
we're excited to announce as of
M60, Lighthouse is integrated
into Chrome Dev tools.  You can
quickly see how your Website is
doing and what to do next
directly in Chrome.  With all of
these tools, we have seen how
easy it can be for companies to
take advantage of these new
capabilities for their web
experience.  To give one example
, there's
Trivago that build a PWA.  It's
on the web, and users can get
to it easily.  And with the new
add to home, it can be launched
from the home screen.  When you
open it, you get a high-class,
immersive experience that can
even work if you're offline.
And built to be resilient
against different network
conditions, so you get a
seamless experience back
online.  But what's really
incredible is this was built by
two three core engineers in just
a couple of months.  And this
is just one example of many.
Leveraging
the modern mobile web is now
the norm around the world.
Whether you're building a PWA
from scratch or leveraging the
latest capabilities on your
existing web experience,
companies everywhere are seeing
a tangible impact on their key
metrics.  With the modern mobile
web, it's possible to easily
build immersive, fully capable
experiences that can reach
billions of people around the
world today.  And now let's turn
our focus to what we're going
to make it easier to develop
apps and grow your business.
Please welcome Francis.
[ Applause ]
FRANCIS: Thanks, Tal.  Hi, I'm
Francis and I lead the Firebase
product team.  Our mission is to
help developers build a better
app and grow a successful
business.  Since I/O 2016, we've
expanded Firebase from a set of
backend services to a broad
mobile platform to solve many of
the problem use face across the
life cycle of an app.  From
helping you build faster and
easier with real-time database
and cloud storage, to helping
you better understand and grow
your app with tools like
analytics and cloud messaging.
Whether you're starting
something new or looking to
extend an existing app, we're
here to help you so you can
channel more of your time and
energy towards creating value
for your users.  And we deliver
all of this in a single, easy to
use SDK available across
platforms.
To date, there are over 1
million developers using
Firebase, and we're humbled so
many of you have taken this
journey with us.  We're deeply
committed to Firebase and
doubling down on our efforts to
help developers succeed.  On
that note, earlier this year
we're excited to have the Fabric
team join us at Google.  Since
launching analytics in 2011, our
teams shared a similar mission.
Now we're working together to
integrate the two  platforms and
bring you the best of both in a
thoughtful way.  We are
bringing Crashlytics to Firebase
to make that our flagship
product.  If you're an existing
customer of Fabric orfire base,
we will pave a smooth
transition.  We are working to
bring the sign in to Firebase
authentication.  You can extend
the app, enable uses to sign in
with a phone number.  They need
to do a one-time verification
and they're in.  With Firebase
Auth, we provide a headless API
so you can have full control and
customize the API
to fit the look and feel of the
app.  In addition to
integrating with Fabric, we have
made many updates over the last
year and I would like to
highlight them for you.  And one
is to manage servers to focus
on build great Apps.  We have
released cloud function for
Firebase.  You can deploy
JavaScript to the cloud and have
it basted on an HTTP request or
other events across Firebase.
For example, you can set up an
example with Firebase off to
automatically send a push
notification when a new user
signs up.  Or set up a function
with storage so you can do
server-side processing with
machine learning when a new
image is uploaded.  Or use
functions with hosting to create
a fully dynamic Website without
managing any servers.
Functions is a great way to
extend your app and enables true
serverless development.
So we just talked about how
Firebase helps you build more
easily.  Let's such gears and
talk about how it can help you
focus
on app quality.  We spend time
testing our apps, but in the
wild, sometimes end users
experience something entirely
different based on diversity of
devices or network conditions.
When apps don't perform well,
it's frustrating for everyone.
That's why we released Firebase
performance monitoring.  You can
monitor with one line of code
to automatically measure the
startup time and network
latency.  And you can add custom
to measure the app.  And you
can drill in deeper to filter
databased on the country, app
version or device type to get a
sense of how users are really
experiencing your app and not
just in your office Wi-Fi.
Performance monitoring is a nice
complement to Crashlytics and
analytics to find the bottle
necks that are impacting user
engagement or business bottom
line.  Speaking of analytics, we
have made a number of updates
on this
front.  Earlier in the year, we
released stream Vue to give you
a real time view of how users
are interacting with the app.
We have added custom parameter
reporting to give you the next
level of insights in addition to
the events that you log.  For
example, say the logged entitles
are happening when a user
passes around a game.  Now you
can get reports for the custom
parameters, the type of game
played or the average number of
points awarded.  We have worked
with the team to give you
insights to which ad on which
screen are earning you the most
so you can really optimize both
your ad revenue along with the
user engagement with the broader
analytics insights you get.
we have also enhanced the
experience with  BigQuery.  Join
it with custom data sets and
perform ad hoc analysis.  You
can use it with data Studio to
create reports.  Essentially,
you can build your own analytics
UI the way you want.  In
addition to  building features,
we have recently launched a
Firebase alpha program that
gives access to  unreleased
products.  This is a great
opportunity to provide early
feedback and help shape
Firebase.  Incorporating
customer feedback is a key part
of the development process and
we look forward to hearing from
developers like you.  Just sign
up at the URL.  Now, we just
shared some of the updates we
have made since last year.  To
learn more and hear what we have
been up to, we'll be hosting
the Firebase Dev summit in
Amsterdam at the end of October.
You can learn more at Firebase
.google.com.  And I look forward
to seeing many of you there.  I
look forward to hearing your
feedback and continue to work
hard to build a
better app and grow a more
successful business.  Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Now I would like to bring Jason
back on.
JASON: Thanks, Francis.  As you
see, we're continuing to work
hard to improve the developer
experience for Google's
products.  Tomorrow morning
you'll hear more about the
products our engineering teams
at Google are building here in
Europe.  Whether it's our
compression team in Switzerland,
amazing compiler and language
work in Denmark, or our cloud
team in Poland that's scaling
the cloud, you'll also have the
opportunity to dive deep into a
number of our products covering
Android to Firebase to the
mobile web.  Plus sand boxes to
help you experience products
firsthand, instructor-led
trainings and codelabs to get
you trained on the latest APIs
today.  In addition to all of
this, we have a large number of
Googlers who are available for
one-on-one consultations through
office hours.  Not only can
they help you understand our
products, but more importantly,
they're here to get your
feedback.  I do have one other
thing to mention before you head
off to the breakout sessions
today.  Last year we partnered
with Udacity to provide  10,000
Android scholarships to European
developers.   We were
overwhelmed by the demand for
the scholarship and were truly
amazed by some of the stories
that came out of it.  Let's take
a look at a story of a former
literature teacher turned coder.
Play the video.
[ Applause ]
So this story is just one of
many that  motivates us to
continue programs like this.
That's why today I'm excited to
announce that we're  extending
our partnership with Udacity to
begin the Udacity scholarship
challenge.  This time, with
enough space for 60,000 aspiring
developers across Europe and
select parts of Amea.
[ Applause ] and we're also
expanding the scope to include
both Android and mobile web
development.  So please visit
the Website to sign up and learn
more.
[ Applause ]
So as you heard from the
speakers today, we're really
excited about the possibilities
for  developers to build some
truly amazing things.  We're
looking forward to getting to
know you over the next two and
hear what's on your mind.  Thank
you, and have fun.
[ Applause ]
>> Hey. Hello and welcome to
Krakow.  For those of you from
Krakow, I thank you for
welcoming us to your, you know,
beautiful city.  Here is
actually a photograph from the
last time I was in Krakow.  When
the temperature was like minus
20 degrees Celsius.  I have been
happy to see some sunshine in
Krakow.  Anyway, my name is Sam
Dutton.  I'm a developer
advocate for the web.  Work for
Google.  Based in London.  I'm
here today and tomorrow with a
bunch of other Googlists -- like
people working on Chrome and
some really brilliant web
developers.  So, please, if you
have questions, come and chat in
the web area.  Come and check
out  Lighthouse and all the
other stuff that we've got.
I wanted to cover some of the
stuff from the keynote in a
little more detail and really
give an overview of the web
today.  You know, I want to give
a high-level overview, but also
some of the business reasons
why I think it makes sense to
build  progressive web apps.  So
we're going to go into that
now.  There will be sessions
later with more technical detail
about building for the web.  So
like you heard earlier, in a
word, the web is big.  There
are, like, now over 5 billion
devices out there that can
access web content.  This is
incredible.  You know, you get
this instant broad reach with
the web.  And this didn't
happen, you know, because of
luck.  You have -- the web is
this open, decentralized
platform.  There are no
gatekeepers.  You know, Websites
get massive reach.  Users get
-- I don't know -- like low
friction.  Which is great.  And
I think, you know, we've all
seen charts like this, mobile
computing is at the heart of
this revolution.  There's
been this explosion of computing
on mobile.  And, you know, we
now use more mobile devices than
desktop computers and so on.
And this is really a challenge
for developers.  We've also
reached this point now -- you
know, particularly notice this
in some  regions -- where a lot
of users coming online are
actually, you know, mobile-only.
They never use a desktop  or a
laptop device.  And, again,
this is a really interesting
challenge for the web.
Of course, on mobile, most users
spend most of their time in
native apps, yeah?  Rather than
the web.  You know, apps that
seem to be more predictable.
They have great reengagement
features.  All this good stuff
in native apps.  Well, I could
cut my presentation short right
now and say, well, build native.
We could all go home.  There
is a flipside to this, though.
And I'm sure you understand it,
particularly app developers in
the audience here.  App usage is
highly concentrated.  Users
tend to only use a few apps.
They see native apps as a big
commitment to device space and
time and cost.  Native apps are
engaging, but only a few are
worth installing.  Based on a
recent study, the average user
is installed like zero apps per
month.  This certainly does not
mean that users are not  using
native apps.  But, you know, by
contrast, from our own data,
something like the average
mobile user visits like around
100 sites per month.  You know,
this is the power of URL
st and the web.
Particularly to me.
And one way to think of the
native and web apps are the
capabilities.  Native apps start
up quickly and reliably when
you tap the icon.  They tend to
work off
offline.  Who here -- when do
you open a web browser when
you're not online?  That's not
what you do.  Native apps have
push notifications and have
access to
device cameras microphones and
so on.  In contrast, the web is
maybe seen as safer, more
respectful of privacy, maybe.
But hasn't had those
capabilities.  What if we could
add those  capabilities so the
web could get that engagement
and meet those UX expectations?
We could have the best of both
worlds.  And, you know, this is
what progressive web Apps
represent.  A user experience
that's good enough -- integrated
enough -- so you can actually
earn a place on the home screen.
And the notification without
having to give up that reach to
get that.  This is really the
core point.  Progressive weapon
apps is really just a term for
--
look -- radically improving the
quality of the  end-to-end user
experience.  We want to learn
from native Apps.  Take what's
best from native apps and bring
that to the web.  And this
requires being really honest
about what matters to user.  So
in order to do that, I think we
need to focus on four things.
We need to make the web fast.
We need to make web experiences
better integrated device, you
know, hardware platforms and
other apps.  We need to make
sure that web experiences are
reliable and we need to keep
users engaged.  So I want to
look at each of those properties
in a little more detail.
From a good native app, users
don't expect janky scrolling or
bad experience.  The web has had
a bad name for slow
performance.  Particularly on
mobile.  Like in-page
performance like scrolling and
so on as well as load
performance.  And in a sense, an
app has to be kind of
invisible.  You know, users
should not be aware that they're
actually loading an app.  It
should just work.  We want to
see that on the web.  This isn't
just a kind of abstract goal.
No, we all know that time is
money on the web.  This data
shows just how much that is
true.  After only like a little
more than 3 seconds, something
like  20% of your users will
abandon the experience.  And,
you know, there's evidence that
users are getting shorter
attention spans.  That this is
getting tighter every year.
So a couple of other numbers,
you know.  It takes the average
web page on mobile 19 seconds to
load on a 3G connection.  You
know, that's really bad for
everyone.  For every 1 second
delay in load, we calculate that
the sites lose something like 7
% of conversion.  So that's
really bad for business.  You
know, we really need to fix
this.  And one of the -- I think
one of the side effects, you
know, thinking about this on the
web -- the reach of the web --
is that you do not have control
where users start in your
experience.  Like which page
they hit first on your site.
You can't dictate, like, you can
with a native app where users
start.  So in working to make
sure that wherever someone
starts, they start fast.  Pages
need to be reliable and fast
from the first time that users
load them.
And to fix this, last year we
started working on a project of
mobile pages, AMP.  This is an
open source project to create
super-fast web pages.  We know
that accessing pages on the
mobile web can be painful, and
AMP is a framework to make sure
they load reliably.  We have
been able to prove this over the
last year.  AMP pages load on
average in less than a second.
They use 10% less data compared
to non-AMP pages.  This is
particularly important for users
where data is expensive.  Where
people are really constrained
by the use of data.  A good
example of this, doing great
work, actually.  The  Weather
Channel, have seen a four time
increase on the AMP articles
from the main page.  That's like
a 90% click through rate.
Which is fantastic.  Since
launching this year.  And an
example of these giant
hailstones.  They get that at
weather.com, and AMP is really
Faying off for them.  Now, AMP
was originally focused on
publishers and static content.
The format has been constantly
evolving.  To support really
critical new features like
E-commerce.  You can use AMP to
build interactive and engaging
pages.  And a lot of E-commerce
partners have really started to
do that.  Our last summit eBay
launched all their product
listing pages on AMP.  Over 15
million pages.  Reliably load in
less than a second.  And
launching product pages
worldwide on app.  Users can go
from searching on Google to
buying on eBay in 3 seconds.  So
for AMP, since launch, there
have been over 2 billion AMP
pages.  900,000 domains.  And
every second 58 AMP pages are
released into the  wild.
Incredible.
If you want to learn more about
AMP, check out Ben Morss'
presentation after lunch today.
We have an AMP training session
tomorrow afternoon as well.
You'll find that AMP and
progressive web apps, they work
really well.  The two attitudes
work well together.  To build
sites, as the slogan goes: to
start faster and stay fast.
So as well as speed, users
expect this app-like integration
for their device hardware,
operating system and other apps.
You know that feeling when you
use a
great native app, you can get
the tight focus and focus on
what you want to achieve and
forget that you're using an app.
Users shouldn't have to feel
like they're easing through a
browser in order to access your
app.  Users shouldn't have to
think about the fact that on the
web, using their phone, tablet
or desktop to complete the
tasks.  One example that's dear
to my heart and worked on is
media.  In the past it's been
really difficult to get media
working on the web.  People felt
like they had to consume media
in an app.  Isn't the case
anymore.  We worked hard across
platforms to make media more
effective and also just to
ensure that, you know -- to be
included in the page and it just
works.  We have great new APIs
to build robust, secure, and
efficient media experiences that
can even work offline.
This is a particularly important
problem to solve, you know.
Over 70% of Internet traffic now
is actually video.  The number
is increasing.  It's incredible.
You know, we need all the
browsers to ensure that we are
getting this complete solution
across different browsers to the
mobile web for media.  So you
have these new APIs that are
improving capability for media
on the web.  I would really
recommend checking out -- this
is Paul Lewis' fantastic
progressive web app.  It's bit.
bit.ly/pwa-media.  It gives
precaching for faster loads.
Orientation chain gives you
instant full screen.  You get
custom controls, thumbnails and
so on.
For me, this is amazing.  This
is amazing to see this happening
on the web.  It's a beautiful
app.  I really recommend that.
So the technology is opening up
the web to even more platforms,
even more experiences.  With web
VR APE, this expressive  pourer
on the web.  And experience
this from VR creators.  Creators
from around the world directly
to the browser.  With company
like SketchFab  bringing this
VR.  I believe they have 1.5
million you can explore.  This
would look wonderful if everyone
here had a VR headset.  Would
also look weird, I guess.  You
would get a sense of what was
possible.  But looking forward
to the advent of augmented
reality, this idea of connecting
information data from the
physical world.  We think the
web is going to play a pivotal
role there as well.
Thinking about integration, I
wanted to touch on new
capabilities also for E-commerce
.  You know, mobile commerce is
a huge deal.  Last year mobile
commerce was worth -- just in
the U.S. -- it was worth
something like $123 billion.
You can imagine from the figure
is for Europe.  This is actually
a fundamental challenge to the
web.  So the web has gone
mobile, but conversions are --
we calculate -- something like
one-third lower on mobile than
desktop.  You know, this makes
sense.  It's hard to enter data
on a phone.  And we need better
integration, you know, because
E--commerce is really all about
removing friction.
So browsers improve this with
autofilaments.  Great.  Today on
Chrome we have something like 9
billion forms of passwords that
are autofilled each month.
Which is good.  But it's not
enough.  The payment request API
goes a step further than this.
This is a W3C standard for
browsers to present a, you know,
a standardized interface for
users to enter payment and
shipping data.  So users get,
you know, consistent secure
experience.  And developers
don't have to reinvent the wheel
every time.  And this goes up
to an E-commerce giant.  Like in
the screen here, the browser
can securely store email
shipping, credit card data on
file for the user.  The browser
can provide a merchant with all
this in one form, pre-populated
to reduce friction.  So you can
see that the web has become a
highly capable platform.  It's
tightly integrated with
operating system, hardware
capabilities.  We just need
better reliability as well.
As present users have not come
to expect the web to work
without a network connection.
And don't even boother to try
when connectivity is slow or
intermittent.  We need to change
that perception.  Web apps must
be reliable.  When a user taps
like on a home screen icon, they
expect it to load instantly and
reliably.  Launched from the
home screen, apps should never,
ever show.  Thinking back to the
'90s when the web was growing
up, does anybody know what this
is?  Maybe not.  Maybe a few
people.  For those who have
never seen them, this is how we
got online.  Probably from some
monolithic desktop somewhere in
the house or basement or
something.  With this modem.
You had to put the whole house
on online mode.  Back in the
day, 56K to me was  exciting.
We grew up on 14K.  What you
have to do is yell to the whole
house, "Don't pick up the
phone!" or that would kill the
connection.  In those days we
knew we were online because
nothing else was happening.
Now, we think of Internet
connectivity kind of more like a
utility like gas or
electricity.  Almost like
oxygen.  Users are expecting
connectivity to be available all
the tomb.  And, you know, we've
become used to this.  And this
means that, you know, seeing
this dinosaur is just not an
option.  Can you imagine if you
went to a native app and you got
some kind of system-generated
error message, you know?  When
the device was offline.  You
would just think, what?  This is
crazy.  We have become used to
this on the web.  We have to
deal with this.  We have to
solve this.  The other problem
is -- as we know -- mobile
phones are not just online or
offline, they're a binary state.
The existence, is it on or is
it off?  Get the problems with
cell connectivity.  You have
four bars here, but you do not
have a working connection.  So
it's not just no connection that
breaks our experience, slow or
intermittent connections can
really be worse for users.
And like I say, mobile apps
should -- as much as I love the
cute little dinosaur -- they
should never show him.  No other
app will show this.  And so in
order for web apps to earn their
place on the home screen, we
need to make them reliable even
when the network is not reliable
.  And this is where service
workers come in.  I wanted to
ask, who has heard of service
workers and feels they have a
pretty good idea of why they're
game changing for the web?  Oh,
that's great, actually.  Hooray!
That's really good to see.
You know, for those of you who
don't know about service workers
, the traditional web model has
been you type in a URL, click on
a link -- whatever.  And the
browser goes to the network,
looks up the web server and
retrieves the resources required
for a page.  Now, the browser,
of course, has an HTTP cache.
You  know, if the network is
down you get a visit from our
friend, the dinosaur.  And the
user experience, obviously, can
be even worse with flakey
connectivity.  So a service
worker is a client-side proxy.
Acts as an intermediary between
your app and the outside world.
You write a service worker in
JavaScript in a separate file,
kind of like a web worker.  And
after that, it's installed and
can respond to
events like network requests.
And the service worker can use
the cache API to cache resources
and work with index DB for data
and so on.  And that enables
you -- the developer -- the site
designer -- to decide when to
use the cache and when to go to
the network.  This is extremely
powerful.
Service workers are acting like
proxy in the outside world.
This means they can handle
incoming events as well as
outgoing requests.  Push
notifications are a great
example of this.  Push messages
are received, you know, by the
operating system via whatever
push service it uses.  And then
passed on to browser.  The push
event from the browser then
wakes up the relevant service
worker and then goes to the push
handler.  It means that the
browser cannot evenly be open.
This is fantastic for reducing
usage of memory and so on.
I think, you know, this kind of
capability for engagement and
reengagement is where
progressive web apps, you know,
are really coming alive.  So, of
course, a truly engaging app
needs to go beyond being just
functional and reliable and
ensure that like the whole
experience is delightful and it
makes it easier, you know, for
the user to do what they need to
do.  Really good experiences on
the web.  You have the right
capabilities, use them at the
right time in a beautiful way.
Twitter is a great example of
this.  They launched a
progressive web app in spring
this year.  They noticed that
their web traffic was growing
and yet the experience wasn't
great.  So they set out to
redesign their mobile web
experiences with PWA.  And this
is a great place to look to see
what can be done on the web.
They had three goals in mind.
They needed to cope with slow or
flakey networks, and they had
to consume less data.  This is
critically important for the
global service for all of their
users.  And Twitter needs to
work well for a huge variety of
smartphones from high end to low
end.  And they have tiny levels
of storage and limited CPU.
For those with phones in your
hand, check out  mobile
.twitter.com.  You can see how
fast and smooth the scrolling is
.  Performance is a huge
priority for Twitter.  They can
access photos and videos for
upload.  You can see a Tweet
going on here.  And, of course,
the web can now send push
notifications.  You know, on
Android,
they appear alongside native
notifications.  Twitter is now
sending out something like 10
million push notifications per
day, which is incredib
What I really love, though, is
Twitter can deliver this
experience at a fraction of the
side compared to native.  You
can see here the difference that
a progressive web app can make.
So how can a  PWA be so small?
Well, you know, when you
download an app, you download
everything that the app needs.
Which is why you get those data
sizes.  But the PWA can leverage
the browser and install more
assets and data as required.
And, again, this is a huge deal.
We need to remember that like
for a lot of users in many
regions, the constraint is
actually from data costs as well
as connectivity.  We need to
remember that and bear that in
mind.  So as you might expect,
Twitter is getting great metrics
for their PWA compared to their
previous mobile experience.
And they're getting something
like a million daily visits.
Users coming from the home
screen icon.  Which is great.  I
have seen the same from a
company called Ola.  This is
like India's largest ride
hailing service.  You
know, their mission was to build
mobility for a billion, you
know, Indians.  Incredible
scale.  We started like six
years ago -- the co-founders.
They would actually drive
customers
if they show up.  Now up to a
million rides a day.  Something
like that.  But that was not
enough when their target was,
like, billions of  users.  What
they needed to do was to target
tier 2 and tier 3 cities.  These
are smaller cities.  20 to
maybe 100K in size.  A lot of
users in those cities get flakey
connectivity and are using, you
know, cheaper smart phones.
And it makes sense for those
people not to actually install
apps because of limited storage
and the cost of data.
So with Ola, their progressive
web app, you get smooth
navigation -- which is great --
a fantastic, robust UX.  And,
you know, great functionality.
Even on low bandwidth.  So since
launch what they've seen is
that things are going well for
them in the cities.  But what's
really nice is they're seeing
great conversions up in the tier
3 cities.  Up like 30%.  This
is a fundamental point that
progressive web apps, allowing
them to address new audiences
and new markets.
One stat I would really like
from them, actually, is that
like 20% of their progressive
web app bookings are actually
from users who had previously
uninstalled the app.  You know,
this is fantastic.  It's worth
remembering that a lot of users
because of device memory
constraints -- whatever -- are
regularly uninstalling apps.
And you don't get that on the
web.  If you want to find out
more about like what Ola and
Twitter have done, check out
their case studies on web
fundamentals.  I'll be sharing a
link to that at the end of the
presentation.  Just briefly
getting back to the topic of
engagement, you know, when a
user visits your site, you can
now prompt them to add the site
to their home screen.  Great
example of doing it really well
is Trivago -- the travel site.
They have a progressive web app
for something like 55 domains
globally.  Incredible.  And the
add to home screen works really,
really well.  This app is now
tightly integrated with the
Android device.  It's in the app
launch like other apps and part
of Android settings -- which is
pretty.
But given this focus on Android,
you might be wondering, well,
is this progressive web app
thing -- like, is this a Google
thing?  And the answer is no.  A
big part of what makes
progressive web apps so
successful is that multiple
browsers are committed to them.
You know, developer adoption is
obviously growing.  But so is
browser support.  Opera,
Samsung, Microsoft, Mozilla are
on board.  The features are
discussed.  And service workers
are in development for Safari,
which is great.  But progressive
web apps are really about the
attitude to building web
experiences that work well for
all your users so you can count
on reaching users that are
important to you.  The word
"Progressive" -- progressive web
apps.  It's not there by
accident.  We need to focus on
the end-to-end user experience
that can give a dramatic impact
to your business.  Even with
users who haven't experienced
the full  power of web apps
because they're using a device
without a certain feature.
Lanco me built this great PWA.
I want to call this out because
something like 60% of their
users are on iOS.  What they
found was when they built their
progressive web app and used the
techniques we're advocating and
you can learn more about today,
they were getting much higher
engagement.  This is fantastic.
You know?  It just means that
this is a good investment for
you no matter what the browser
mix is that you're  targeting.
Gartner recently published a
report advocating that PWAs
should be part of a mobile
development strategy.  And, you
know, this idea that progressive
web apps will begin to replace
general purpose apps.  So I know
this, you know, this sounds
great.  But I also know that
reality sinks in, you know, you
go back to your day job.  And
you think about building a
progressive web app that can
seem like this huge undertaking.
But implementing these
techniques need not be this
monolithic refactoring task.  I
want to talk about some ways to
get started.
First and foremost, you need
security, yeah?   HTTPS is table
stakes for progressive web
apps.  Keep your users and
business safe.  This is not just
for sites that work with
sensitive data.  You know, any
site can be a target that's
vulnerable for attack.  And the
green lock, you know, indicates
that site is secure.  It is a
secure connection between your
users and your site.  This means
three things.  The user must be
able to trust that the site is
actually you, not a scammer or a
phisher.  They must be assured
that no one can tamper with the
content.  And then be sure that
no one is listening to the
intersection between them and
your site.  The web has this
tremendous reach and lack of
friction.  Keeping users safe is
absolutely Paramount.  And for
this reason HTTPS is mandatory
for many of the APIs on the web.
Including service worker,
geolocation, camera access, so
on.  So once you have moved to a
secure domain, three approaches
to moving to a progressive web
app.
You can build from the ground up
.  You can start with a simple
version or focus on a single
feature.  Just want to have a
quick look at these.  So
starting from the ground up
makes sense.  When you go
through a re-design.  Starting
from scratch, you can build that
app-ness in from the start
using service workers and so on.
OLX is a great example of
this.  They launched their site
for classified ads in many India
.  Providing great markets and
they have seen fantastic
improvements to times to
interactive, drops in bounce
rates and so on.  They wanted to
reengage with their users,
yeah?  Including their mobile
app users.  And they've had
fantastic results with that.
And, again, they built this
right from scratch.  But, of
course, not everyone can do
this.  You know, starting from
scratch is not realistic
as an example.  But a different
approach is Air Berlin.  They
built this post-check-in app
where you can get all the
details.  Your flight.  They
weren't able to start
everything from scratch.  Check
out their stuff.  They have done
a beautiful job of this.  You
can get your boarding pass, all
those details, even when the app
is, then, offline.  Now, the
final strategy is, you know,
just the define is to pick on
one particular strategy.
Whether.com have done a great
job with this with
notifications.  I would really,
really recommend -- they've
rolled this out in like 60
languages -- if you're looking
at UX for notifications, I would
really recommend you look at
what they've done.  They done a
beautiful job of this within a
PWA experience.
And they've seen, you know,
great results from this.  A
million opt ins within a month
and so on.  So check out their
work.  I thoroughly recommend
that.  So, you know, I would
look at these  different -- if
you're thinking of building a
progressive web app.  Come along
to Ewa's talk  later.  It's an
excellent talk and she'll talk
about how you can get started.
Great momentum, different
verticals, you know, with travel
companies on the web.  We've
seen, like, publishers.
Partners like Forbes.  Forbes
has seen double in user
engagement since the launch of
their PWA, which is fantastic.
And in E-commerce sites as well.
Fandango, Alibaba, they have
all invested successfully in web
Apps.  And newer services like
ride sharing companies.  This is
a sample of some of the people
actively working with PWA
s.  Check out their work.  They
have done beautiful work
building great sites.  And
they're just finding ways to
start down this path.  Investing
in -- I
don't know -- in the mobile web
and getting down this path of
building progressive web Apps.
So I think progressive web apps
for the company.  Giving them
reach and capability.  The
ability to target new audiences
and new markets which is
incredibly exciting on the web.
If you want to learn more about
this, we have some great
sessions coming up.
Some good presences today and
tomorrow.  We'll have, like I
say, a lot of expert web
Googlers on hand to answer your
questions and solve your
problems.  I would strongly
recommend the training sessions
from Sara Clark and her team.
Really good people running those
sessions.  And if you want to
find out more, please check out
web fundamentals like case
studies, resources at
developers.google.com/web.  Most
of all, please feel free to
come and talk to us.  Any of the
Googlers -- there's a bunch of
web Googlers here.  We're here
to learn what you're doing on
the web.  What we can do to make
the web better and to help you,
you know, build better
experiences for all your users.
Thank you very much.  And we'll
see you around.  Thank you.
[ Applause ]
.
>> Testing testing test
ing, testing testing testing
.
>> Testing testing testing, this
is a test for Google Developer
Days.
This is a captioning test.
.
>> Hello, everyone. My name is
re
Rebecca Franks and where will
speak to you about Android
things and how I think it is the
IoT platform for everyone.
What is Android things? Android
things is an extension of the
Android platform for IoT and
embedded devices.  We have known
Android for years, but it was
available for us on our watches,
and also in our cars with
Android auto.  And now, with
Android things, you can have
Android on any devices that you
can imagine.
So Android Things is ideal for
powerful, intelligent devices
that need to be secure.  Some
examples of where Android Things
work well is in the retail
industry, for things such as
interactive ads, or vending
machines, powered by Android.
And also, in the business
industry, with things such as
cameras, access control and
smart access meters.
And in the logistics industry,
you can think of using Android
Things in asset tracking or
predictive service.
But Android things is also very
suitable for home automation.
So, a smart doorbell, or an
energy monitoring system will
also do well with Android
Things.
So, a question that you are
probably wondering is: How
similar is Android's
developments to Android Things?
And the answer is, it is very,
very similar.  So when you are
developing for Android Things,
you are using the Android SDK.
So all the APIs, and all the
things that you learned as an
Android developer are similar
for you to do Android Things.
You are also using Android
Studio, so you are hold
ing it to your Android Things
device.
You can also use the Play
Services, the nearby API or
vision API, you can use on
Android Things.  And because it
is Android as well, you can use
there
the Firebase ATKs.  You can
also use the cloud platform, so
the core, you can use with
Android things.
And the base part is because it
is -- you can use any -- if
you are a big fan of Java, you
can do that with Android Things
as well.
So now we have seen how similar
Android things is to Android
developments.  But there's a
couple of differences you have
to keep in mind when you are
developing for Android Things.
So the first is you know the
play store you are shipping your
app on to.  Your app is running
on the device, and there's no
such thing as a play store where
you can go and install web apps
from.  And there is also a set
of APIs that are available to
you.  So things such as your
notifications
--
And when you are developing for
Android Things, you are using
custom hardware, that's the
biggest difference when you are
developing for Android versus
Android Things.  So what you
hold is what you ship.
So when you are on the Play
Store and downloading from
the app store, you are shipping
the hardware and the software
together.
a single-purpose device.  And
what I mean by that is your app
and your platform device, that
is the only thing that will be
there, there is nothing else, so
the users are not install ing
anything else on the device.
And then you are deploying to
your clients.
typical stack of a traditional
Android
mobile device.
a rich set of APIs for our apps
to use.
And applications provide a
userface for general use cases,
such as our launchers, or
phones, and our messaging apps.
With Android Things, we are
using a couple of different APIs
and applications that have been
available for you as an Android
developer.  So the default apps
are removed, you no longer have
the messaging capabilities on
Android Things.
And it also means that the APIs
are monitoring behavior.  So if
you have
notifications --.
And now, when you are developing
for Android Things, you get the
Android Things support as part
of your development.  So things
such as Peripheral I/O and
device management, we will go in
detail to those a little bit
later.
So Android Things uses a system
on module architecture, or an
SoM architecture.  The system is
designed around a core
computing module that is located
on a bigger breakout board in
prototyping and development.
And when you go into production,
this is used on a platform that
you would ship to your client.
This reduces costs and
simplifies development because
the hybrid design is in the
sample.
The Google package creates a
stable bed to rely on.  So if it
changes, you don't need to
worry as much because the
package is supported.
And
it makes it a lot easier to
use.
And this is before you ship them
to your clients.  This can be
very
, and we are using the
architecture design to simplify
costs as Google handles the
complexity for you.
So when you are developing with
Android Things, there's a couple
of things that are managed by
Google and things that are
managed by you.  So that
includes the framework, the
hardware libraries, and the
Linex Kernel, you don't need to
worry about that.  And you as a
developer need to worry about
the apps and the user drivers.
So the console is what you
would use as a developer to ship
to your devices.
So you would manage your IoT
product on the console, you can
download the latest Android
things on the image, and you can
build factory images that
contain OEM applications along
with the system image.
console itself, you also push
OTA to your clients, and if you
go to partner.Android.com/
things/console, you can see this
.
And taking a quick look at the
console, though, this is what
you would see if you are
developing your app.
So, this is the -- I created
this candy dispenser, and where
will set the -- this is what you
would receive.
And on this console, you can see
where you would download on
what you are shipping.
bundle, and this is
what contains what you want to
ship, as well as your size.  You
can also use the version of
Android Things from your core,
and then you can download this
factory image on the devices
that you are using.
you are already using a device
in production, you can use the
same process, select the bundle,
SX
and your image.
Of course, so we have a little
bit of background on how Android
Things works and what it is, so
I will take a quick look at how
we develop for Android Things.
ill get started with Android
Things, you need to purchase or
obtain a Developer Kit.  There
are two that I like, the NXPI.
MX7D, or the
raspberry
Raspberry Pi 3.  You start up
the device and then you would
have Android Things running on
it.  From this point on, you can
connect over to a Raspberry Pi
or cable.
the NXP more than the Raspberry
Pi.
And we can use custom hardware
with the devices.  And in order
to access these different
hardware
peripherals, there are
different options we need to
use.  So I like to think of it
as two different ways, one being
the difficult way and one being
the easy way.
And the peripheral I/O extension
is what I think of as more of a
difficult way, but basically
what this gives you is access to
all the different protocols
that you might be used to if you
have done any kind
of development forward.  So
things such as your GPIO, or PWM
protocol, you can get access to
them using the Peripheral I/O
measure.  This does sound a
little bit tricky, if this is
not your thing, you can head to
the per
Peripheral Driver Library on
GitHub, and that allows you to
use things with your Android
Things application.
You can use a similar motor, or
all that is available to your in
your link down below.
And so,
I like to think of it as, you
don't know what you are doing
with Android things, you can get
to the GitHub library.  If you
want local access, you can use
the standard protocols.
to quickly build an app.  This
is basically what we have on the
screen here is
a board.  So this is simple,
why are Android Things involved,
but we have Android Things
control the LED when the battery
is pressed.  So what we're
going to do, we're going to have
two pins that we are using in
this case.
And this is what I like to refer
to as the Pinout Diagram.  If
you have these devices, you will
see that there's a button on
the Raspberry Pi.  So what you
want to do now, you are going to
be using
BCM12 and 21.
So in the studio, you go into
and create an application, and
in the Android studio, we create
the project.  And then we would
link it to Android Things as an
option we want to build for.
We can choose to have -- and
then automatically, it compounds
the dependencies.
is -- to make sure we have the
latest version.
And this indicates that we are
using the library in store.
And then, we add
ed -- when the device re-boots,
it automatically views the
activity we created.  You need
to add the stuff yourself if you
have not run through the
create -- your Android Things
project from scratch.  We need
to use it yourself.
what I'm going to do is use the
button from the GitHub support
library that we saw earlier.
So I'm just using it within
cradle, putting it in my cradle
file, and now I get access to a
button.
So I would create a new button
by setting a new equals new
Button, and I give it what we
were talking about earlier.  In
this case, BCM6, Pressed When
Low.  This is not the same as
Android.widget.button, it is a
different thing from the Android
support line.  And now what you
can do is set an on-click
listener on the button.
And all we're going to do in
this case is set the value to
true or false.
And now, this might be a little
bit confusing for us, but we
will get into the -- next.
The next thing we need to do is
make sure that we close the
access that we have.  This makes
sure that we free up any
resources we were using before.
To get access to the led that
we had before, we go to the
Peripheral Manager Server API.
This is provided by the Android
support library, you can use it
by importing the compiled
dependency.  And so we would
just then say, service.open
Gpio, and then we would set the
direction out initially low.
And then we will set it as true
or false if we need to.
And now,
we get a false when the user
lets up their finger.
And then you need to close up
this as well, you are
not -- you are going to LED
GPIO.closed.
And then you have a blinking LED
powered by Android Things.
So now that we've seen how to
build a simple Android Things
project, there's a couple of
examples I want to go through
that I want you to look to if
you go to
hacksterio/Google.
Smith, the Edison Candle.  This
is a candle powered by Android
Things and this example is for
you to understand how to go from
a prototype to production and
all the different things you
would need in order to get
there.  So be sure to check out
that project on Hackster.
And the next project I want to
highlight is the piano hero,
this is on display if you go to
the Android Things stand.  This
is basically using a keyboard,
power up Android Things, you can
play guitar hero with a piano.
And then one other one I would
like to talk about is my only
one, this is an electricity
monitoring app.  And in South
Africa, we suffer regularly from
power outages.  And I have this
problem where I don't know if I
have at power at home versus
when I didn't, I built this app
using Android Things and
Fairbase ATKs.  This runs on my
Pi at home, and when I don't
have power, I
can determine if the power is
off or back on.  It also keeps
track of how long I have had
power for at my house, which is
really useful.
How I did that, with Firebase,
you get a nice
HDK, connected, and this tells
you if you are connected to the
internet or not.  So this is
just a monitor for connectivity,
but my network is more reliable
than my power.
So you add a value event
listener on this. And then for
this part, on the snapshot, you
can determine if you are online
or not.  And if you are, it is
service equals true and you add
the disconnect listener.  This
is where it is super powerful.
And the listener says, when this
client disconnects from the
server, set the value to true or
false.  And on the server, I'm
using the Firebase cloud
functions to determine if I
should send a notification or
not.  I'm monitoring this, and
if anything changes, a push
notification is sent out to the
device.
actually built myself is what
we call an AI Candy Dispenser.
So this one has been built by
Alvaro Viebrantz, you can find
it on hack
Hackster as well.  It is using
the TensorFlow API offline on
the device.  So how it works,
when you press the button, it
asks you to please show me a
photo of a cat or a lion or
something like that.
And then you have to quickly
search for one on the internet,
or maybe you have some of those
objects lying around, and then
show this image to the device,
and then it uses TensorFlow to
try to classify the image it has
on the device, and then if it
is a cat or a lion, you got it
right, and it dispenses candy.
This is all powered using
Android Things and the
TensorFlow libraries.
So I encourage you to add your
project
tohackster io/Google.  So if
you are using Android things,
please share so everyone else
can see.
So why Android things? It is the
power of Android in your own
hands on these devices.  Google
manages the complexity of
automatic and secure objects,
and it is easier for you as a
developer to manage the same
thing.
If you are curious about
learning more, at 1:00, there's
an instructor-led training about
hands-on with Android Things
and creating your own IoT
devices.  I will be available if
you have any questions, and if
you are on your way out
, you can look at your own
device yourself.
So, thank you very much.
(Applause).
Test.
EWA: Hello, everyone, my name is
Ewa Gasperowicz.  I'm a
developer engineer at Google.
And I'm very happy to see you
today and especially in the
beautiful city of Krakow which
I'm very proud of.  So welcome.
[ Applause ]
My intention today is to shed
some light on the process of
transforming an existing Website
into a progressive web op.  We
and my team recently went
through a few such processes.
And I would like to share with
you some of the things we found
out on the way.
Probably by now you've heard a
little bit about progressive web
apps.  The notion of PWAs is
making rounds in the industry.
And if you have been to a
session about PWA in the morning
-- have you been?  Plenty of
people.  You probably know all
of them by now.  But even with
that, progressive web apps are
experiences that combine the
best of the web and the best of
the apps.  They are web
experiences, which means they
have the wonderful reach of the
web.  There is no installation
and every new experience is just
one click away.
At the same time, they are used
to extend the capabilities of
modern apps.  It means they are
fast and don't wait for the user
to load or react.  They are
integrated, which means they
feel like a natural part of your
device.  They are variable,
which means they load and
operate no matter the
circumstances.  And they are
engaging, which means they give
you pleasure from using them.
This all sounds very new and
very exciting.  But is it
really?  Some years back when I
first got my hands on a
smartphone and started to browse
the web, I totally expected it
to work just like on  desktop.
My expectation was that if I
visit a URL, it actually will
load, right?  That's not too
much to ask.  And I expected it
to load quickly within my
attention span.  And keep in
mind that for people like me --
people like me don't want to get
stuck on the leading screen
forever.  If for people like me,
the "Forever" usually means 30
seconds.  That's the reality we
live in.  30 seconds is already
forever in mobile.  I wanted it
to work fast.  I wanted it to
work smoothly so I could enjoy
using the app.  And I wanted to
have an easy way to access the
content and be fully immersed in
the experience.
So those expectations are pretty
old.  It's not anything new to
expect your Website to work
really well just in the way we
describe progressive web apps.
So why do we even introduce this
concept of progressive web apps
as a new concept if all we want
to talk about are actually
Websites just done so well that
the user has ever pleasure from
using it?  We use progressive
web app notion to build a mental
model and to communicate better
about our expectations towards
the modern web.  It just makes
it easier for us to wrap our
heads around.  It also allows us
to effectively communicate the
expectations and the new
possibilities that are coming to
the web.  And by talking about
PWA, we can encode those
expectations into didn't models.
Here you can see three of the
models.  The first one is
describing behaviors of a
progressive web app.   Fast,
integrated, variable and
engaging.  The second one is a
PWA checklist.  If you just
Google it and go to the first
result, you
will see a checklist of features
that you can pay attention to
in order to enable
progressiveness in your app.
And finally, we encode a set of
tools in a tool called
Lighthouse.  Lighthouse can
audit the Website and give a
report how progressive or not
progressive it is.
So these are three different
models, three different formats
of describing a progressive web
app, but actually the notion is
the same.  I'm going to use
different tools like this today
to talk about progressiveness
and thousand achieve it on your
own Website.
Okay.  Getting from a Website to
a progressive web app is a
process.  It looks roughly like
this.  As most of the projects,
it starts with a thought -- an
idea -- right?  In my case, it's
coffee, so here you go.  We
start with coffee.  And by
drinking coffee, you can also
ponder about the scope of the
project.  About the things you
want to achieve.  After that,
once you're done with your
coffee, you can go and analyze
your Website to understand your
starting point.  You need to
have a reference point once
you're done implementing PWA
features to know how you do.
Next step is to prioritize.  And
the truth is, we rarely have
the resources to implement all
of the stuff at once, right?
And the cool thing about PWA is
that it's a modular concept.
It's not an emerging technology.
You can actually pick and
choose what deployment and in
what order.  I'm going to talk a
little bit about that.  You
should set your user base and
your business needs.  So always
talk to your stakeholders
while prioritizing PWA features.
Then you should prepare your
tools.  Every job is easier when
you choose the right tools to
perform it.  Finally, you can
just execute your plan and
implement the features.  I'll
talk about some issues you can
encounter at this step.  It's a
broad topic and by no means can
I be exhaustive here.  At the
end there is sometimes an
overlooked step.  The
evaluation.  Measure and
evaluate.  It gives you both a
nice summary of how you did in
your migration from Websites to
progressive web app, but it can
also be a very valuable starting
point for your next iteration
on the project.  This is how the
process looks like.  And we're
going to follow it throughout
this presentation.  Okay.  So
while drinking our coffee, let's
talk about the scope of PWA.
What this notion actually
includes.
We know the goal.  We want to
deliver the delightful user
experience.  But what are the
actual practical deliverables?
Usually when we talk about PWA,
we talk about these three core
technologies first.  We talk
about service worker and related
techniques like caching.  They
allow you to offer your users an
offline experience.  But also
they can improve reliability of
your app which can now work
under the circumstances and also
positively influence the speed
for your second-time visitors.
Push notifications allow you to
send the user a message and
bring them back to your app or
reengage them.  Add to home
screen allows you to make your
app feel like a first-class
citizen on your mobile.  The
user can install it to their
home screen and access it
easily, making it easy for them
to go back to your app again.
And a lot of it is enabled by
HTTPS, which is a bottom line of
a secure web experience.  I
like to call these three
features a native parity core
because they actually allow us
these days to do on the web the
same things that just recently
were possible only on native
apps.  And while they make me
super-excited about the future
of the web, I think there is
much more to
progressive web apps than just
the native priority.  Well, list
fill some of this white space.
Let's add the performance
factor.  I cannot stress enough
how important it is to make your
site fast and performant.
Preferably before you implement
service worker rules and
add to home screen.  A lot of
techniques like optimizing your
assets, especially images, a
docking script, and making good
use of browser cache.  Getting
this part right is especially
important for your  first-time
visitors who do not have a
service worker yet or are on
browsers that don't fully
support it yet.  They have to
rely on the network
in order to get to your site, so
by making it more performant by
using different techniques, you
make life easier for them as
well.
As a matter of fact, going for
PWA features is, in general, a
very good audit opportunity.
Not only for performance issues,
but also for UX issues and for
other problems with your site.
It is crucial to make your
Website of generally good
quality before adding the
additional complexity of PWA
features.  I personally call it
PWA readiness.  Especially if
you plan to implement offline
down the line, you need to be
respectful of user resources
like bandwidth and memory.  And
you don't want to push through
the cache a bloated Website.
Similarly, you don't want to
send push notifications to the
user only for him to come back
to your site and discover he can
not perform the action he was
asked to do because your forms
are convoluted or are not
accessible, right?  So first
reck to fix basic issues with
your site and only then will we
move on to the PWA features.
All right.  Our site is PWA
ready, it's  performant, we
already have an idea how to
implement service worker, push
and add to home screen.  Is this
all we need to care about?  The
web is always evolving.  And
only recently two features where
were added to the platform:
credentials management and
payment.  I'm sure there will be
more APIs coming that will make
your user experience even
better on your Website.  So you
always need to keep an open mind
about what's coming and what
you can use in your projects.
Finally, all of this is nothing
if you don't top it off with a
great UX.  Good UX, engagement,
and without it you might find
the gain from implementing all
the underlying features is less
than expected.  Just as I
described with the push all of
the service worker.  So always
make sure that all of these
features are tied by a nice and
smooth UX.
Finally, it's also a great
comfort and a good practice to
make decisions based on data.
For this, you need to measure
things.  Both before and after
the implementation of the PWA
feature.  Actually throughout
the whole process.  So that's
the full scope -- in my opinion
-- of PWA functions.  It's much
more than just the service
worker, right?  These are all
the areas that you should take
into account or at least think
about when investigating how to
approach adding PWA features to
your site.  That's a big chart
and a lot to digest and quite a
lot of steps.  How do you
implement it?  One at a time.
So let's start.
With our coffee, we understand
the scope of our project.  Let's
actually start it.  We start
with analyzers.  First you need
to audit the Website in order to
understand the current state of
the app.  And in order to do
that, we provide a very good
tool -- Lighthouse.  Lighthouse
is for web diagnostics.  It's a
Chrome extension that allows you
to measure how close your web
app is to a progressive web app.
When you start the  extension
-- Lighthouse -- and run your
Website through it, it gives you
back a score and a report that
summarizes the state of your app
for you.  This is how the
report -- average report might
look, right?  There are
different areas where you need
to pay attention to.  And there
is also a long list with
explanations why your Website
got this score and not another.
Together with the links of
thousand make things better.
Apart from being a diagnostic
tool, it's also a very good
educational tool.  Just by
checking reports on your
Website, you can
learn a lot about how you can
make this Website better.
One feature I wanted to pull out
was the share button in the top
right corner.  Apart from
sharing, it allows you to save
this report in JSON format.  I
really encourage you to save
your report before you start any
projects.  Because it provides
you a benchmark and a reference
point that you can compare to
once your project finishes.
Of course, Lighthouse is not the
only tool.  There are other
ones.  And most of them actually
also allow you to save the data
somewhere.  So if you have only
15 minutes to analyze your
site, record and save the
results from the tools mentioned
above.  Lighthouse, the
security panel in Chrome
DevTools, page
spied insights, web
webpage test.  It will help you
after implementation.  We
analyzed the Website and know
exactly how it performs in
different areas.  Now it's time
to prioritize.
This is all the areas I
mentioned you should take into
account.  So the question is,
where to start?  I would say,
start at
the beginning.  Ensure PWA
readiness.  No amount of PWA
features will solve unresponsive
clutter or a janky Website.  So
before you add new complexity,
you want your site to be as
lean, smooth, working and
optimized as reasonably
possible.  In particular, based
on your outcome, of course,
because each site differs, you
might look into areas like
optimizing images.  Is there a
gain?  Remove unnecessary code.
Leverage browser caching before
even switching to service
workers.  Avoid blocking code.
And divide big, monolithic
JavaScript into smaller chunks
if adequate for your Website.
These are common things that are
very well known.  But, you
know, as your Website evolves
over time, sometimes they're
overlooked and they kind of go
offtrack.
So going for PWAs is actually
good at the moment to stop for a
moment, audit them again and
fix the issues if your encounter
any.  Let me show you an
example.  Sometime ago I was
working on a  Women
Techmakers.org site.  I was
preparing it for some upcoming
PWA features.  Here you can see
some -- here you can see the
network panel of the Chrome
Devtools.  What I did here, I
sorted by size.  And focusing
only on the very top of the list
, you can find the best targets
for optimization.  Here the two
biggest files were the API file
and the hero image you can see
on the home page.  The question
was, how to optimize those?
Start with the hero image.  It's
a hero image.  It needs to be
as big as Vueport, but not
bigger than that.  So I created
other versions of the file.  I
saved the medium and small I
thinks.  I added a few break
points to my  CSS.  And as an
outcome on the page, I got a 21%
gain of rate of the images on
that site.  And this all took
maybe six minutes all
together to perform.  And this
21% gain -- just by optimizing
one image.  Really small
improvements can lead to big
gains in this area.  Similarly,
I was able to replace heavy
assets with simpler ones.
Previously we used the player
API for video on the page.
Which, today, is actually
possible to do a simple iFrame
with the correct configuration
to run the video.  So I replaced
it with the i frame, and the
whole 400 kilobytes
were deleted.  It's one line of
code.  We realized we didn't
use the full extent of the
Logstash library, just a few
functions.  Replace with the
core, and 20 kilobytes down --
it's not a great deal amount of
download data, but those small
gains do add up.
Finally, we started to leverage
browser caching better.  In the
previous version of the site, we
were caching our assets --
sorry.  We were  versioning our
assets by the build version.
This means that with each build
of our site this number changed
and the name of the file
changed.  Which means the
browser would need to download
it again, even if this
particular asset did not change.
Just because the overall build
for the site changed.  So we
switched to the content-based
caching instead.  Now only if
the content changes we change
the hash and therefore the file
name.  And this way we can
optimize the browser caching.
This allows the user to download
much more resources than in the
previous use case.  So you can
see all of those changes were
pretty simple and were very easy
to achieve.  And they did add
up to big gains on our Website.
Once you are PWA ready, you
should ensure safety of your
users.  We want to develop
great, progressive web apps in
order to
leverage the frictionless and
accessible web out there.
But the web is also dangerous.
So keeping your users safe is
hugely important.  So I would go
for HTTPS as one of the first
things you implement on your
site if you go for a PWA.  Also,
a lot of new web APIs are
actually requiring HTTPS to be
enabled on your site.  So it
should be a natural step to
take.  Once your site is PWA
secure, you can simply follow
your business need.  And this
pretty much depends on your site
and your business.  For
example, if user acquisition is
important for your business, you
should focus on perf.  Because
performance site that loads
quickly on the first visit
allows you to gain some more
users.
If you have a huge bounce rate
because of unperformant site,
users don't see it in the first
place.  It so for user
acquisition, focus on perf.  If
you are focusing on users in low
connectivity areas, then you
focus on offline.  Implementing
service worker and the offline
experience.  This is where the
big gain for your users is.
User retention, focus on push
and add to home screens.  This
allows you reengage users in
your experience.  And you can
pick and choose because PWA is
modular and you can see which
areas benefit your business best
.
All right.  Now we are choosing
the tools.  And there is a lot
of tools out there, right?
There is a lot of tools.  There
are some starter packs and
generators for different
frameworks and libraries that
allow you to build a progressive
web app from scratch.  But I
want to focus on migrating an
existing Website to a PWA.
That's why I will give a
shoutout to one library in
particular.  It's the  Workbox
library.  When developing
offline  experience, things
might get a little bit fiddley.
There is also a lot of
boilerplate because many  tasks
are simply repetitive -- like
caching.  So my advice is, don't
do things by hand.  They might
bite you.  Remove both stress
and bowler plate with  Workbox.
And luckily at quarter to 3:00
we have a wonderful workshop for
you for Website with PWA with
Workbox on the floor.  If you
want to see the ins and out you
can get from the library for
your Website, check out that
training.
Yay.  Finally.  We go to the
point where we can implement our
PWA features.  This is the
hardest part because it differs
a lot from project to project,
right?  So instead, let me share
with you an example of how we
solved an offline dilemma in the
tech maker's site.  It helps
you solve PWA features in this
case, offalone.  This is a Women
Techmakers slide.  It's a
beautiful site.  A visual
experience.  Lots of images.
Really, really nice inside.  And
I was supposed to implement
offline experience for it.  If I
wanted to save all of this to
cache, that would be very, very
heavy.  So  caching all the
images was rather a no-go.
How about no
images?  Well, the site looks
kind of ugly.  But it's also
unusable.  I can't go to a
different sub page because the
menu button is  missing.  It's
unusable.  Therefore caching no
images was also a no-go.  How
do we find a middle point?  How
do we negotiate this?  Well, I
took a different look at the
Website to really understand its
structure.  I divided images by
function.  Let's take a look.
The yellow images are the
navigational and action images.
They are there so the user can
navigate and perform activities
on our Website.  Therefore,
they're crucial for the site to
be fully functional.  Then the
red ones are branding and
priority.  They allow you to
connect with your user.  They're
very important
.  The end user recognizes which
suit they're looking at.
They're  high-priority images.
The blue ones are decorative.
They make the site look nice.
They add to the experience.  But
if they're missing, they don't
break anything.
The site is less rich, but still
usable.  And the third type of
picture, the green ones, I call
informative.  It looks nice and
adds to the graphical layer of
the site, but they also convey
some message within them.  So
how do we deal with those four
different types of images?
Well, for navigation and action
images, I just inlined them with
SVG.  They're usually small, so
it's easy to do.  And if you
embed them in your cached HTML,
they're going to be there.
Problem solved.  Don't need a
caching strategy with them
because if HTML is there, your
images are there as well.
Now, branding and priority, I
want always -- I want for them
to always be there because
they're important for me because
of my business case.  So I
precached them.  When a user
enters the site, in this case I
precached them with the workbox
library.  And they are important
and without them, the
experience would be broken.
Now, decorative, I employed the
run time cache strategy.  As the
user navigates through the site
and online, I download the
pictures and save to the cache.
There is high likelihood that
the user will want to go back to
the sites later on when they're
offline.  But if the user
doesn't venture to some parts of
my site, I just go and fall
back.  A place holder, right?
The site maybe looks less rich,
but it's usable and I didn't
blow the cache with a lot of
decorative  images.
Now, informative images are kind
of fancy ones in the slot.
Because here I use the full
power of the service worker.
Service worker is just a
JavaScript file, which means you
can put a lot of logic into it.
Here I want not save all to
the user cache, but still convey
the message, who are the
sponsors?  So instead of the
logos, I generate the images on
the fly in service worker by
using the alt text from the
image tag, right?  So instead of
saving all the images, I
generate them on the fly to not
have an image,
but still convey the message.
This is an example of how you
deal with images and for
different strategies.  The
message I want to convey is that
you should really look deeply
into the structure of your site
and type of content you have and
try to divide it and come up
with different strategies to
different parts of your company.
And this way you can provide
the best user experience for
your users while offline.
Okay.  Once we implement
everything, we need to evaluate
the site.  And this often is an
overlooked step.  Remember when
I told you to save the
snapshots of data from before
the implementation?  Well, now
they come in handy.  You can go
again through the audit propose
and record all the same traces
and record the outcome with the
previous version.  Hopefully it
will give you a surge of joy as
you see metrics improve on your
site.  However, there is one
caveat.  Metrics are helpful,
but they're only metrics.
Getting 100 on Lighthouse is
great.  I can assure you, it
feels really good.  And it may
also help to convince your
stakeholders about the impact
you achieved and
maybe get your project funding
for the next dooration, but it
does not answer how users are
finding your changes, right?
And as a matter of fact PWA
influences many areas of your
app.  It influences the UX.  For
example, now you have to
consider a lot of offline
scenarios.  For example, how
users will try to buy your
product when they're in offline
mode.  It influences your
workflow.  You need to add to
user's cache, and it's hard to
do it through managing the
process manually.  Maybe invest
in some build tools and into
your workflow optimization.
Influences your measuring.  Now,
a lot of the interactions might
happen offline.  You need to
implement offline analytics.
And it might influence your SEO,
so You should check if nothing
changed there or things were
even improved on the SEO part.
So that's the process.
That's how we got from the
Website to PWA.  First we
analyzed the Website, then we
prioritize
ed and what we wanted to focus
on.  We get a set of tools to
perform those actions.  Then we
implement our changes.  And then
we evaluate it.  An important
thing is, this can be an
iterative process, right?  With
each ending point where you
measure can also be a starting
point for the next iteration of
your Website.  The web
development and your Websites
will develop over time as well,
and your users will change over
time, so you need to keep going
back and checking what can be
done to provide an experience
for them.
Luckily, you're not alone in
this road for perfection of your
Website.  There is a lot of
resources.  And a lot of them
are available today at this
conference.  There is Lighthouse
too.  You can use it both as a
Chrome extension and online.
And there is one real life
Lighthouse on the first  floor,
so feel free to give it a try.
There are site clinics where you
can look at the healthiness of
your site with Googlers.  We
have some office hours.  If you
have questions after this
session or want to talk to me,
I'll be present in the office
hours area on the first floor
after this session.  There is
the training, quarter to 3:00,
that works through Workbox.  And
the progressive section on
developers.google.com that I
encourage you to check out.
Thank you very much.  I hope you
enjoyed the session, and see
you around.
[ Applause ]
>> Hello, I'm Ben Morss, a
developer advocate at Google.
I'm here to talk about PWA --
progressive web apps.  If you
have seen Sam's talk, ewa's
talk, you have heard this use.
And AMP, accelerated mobile
pages.  I'm curious, who has
heard the acronym PWA before?
All right. maybe two-thirds.
How about AMP?  Okay.  Very
good.  In the context, not a
guitar amp.  They had amps back
here.  This is the other kind of
AMP, accelerated mobile pages.
And PWA and AMP, putting them
together, how this is powerful,
elegant and easy to do.  And
I'll show you an example of how
to do this called the shadow
reader.
The first question is: why?
Progressive web apps are these
immersive full-screen app-like
experiences on the web.  And
accelerated mobile  pages are
best known for somewhat simpler
kinds of pages.  Maybe for
publishers, maybe a way to get
to Google's cache.  And kind of
a simplification of the web for
performance reasons.  How do
these things fit together and
why bother with this?  It's
because of what I call the web
app dilemma.
So let's go back about 18 years
ago.  Back then web pages were
simple.  If there was any
complexity, it was on the
backend.  Perl, maybe PHP making
things happen.  Generating
HTML.  The frontend was just
HTML.  Maybe some CSS -- which
was brand new back then -- and
not a whole lot of this cute
language called JavaScript.
JavaScript was not like a real
language, it was a toy language
back then  used for little
things.  Remember this thing
over here, you can move your
cursor over the button and it
would change color.  That was
pretty cool.  That was
JavaScript.  That was pretty
easy.
Today it's more complicated.
There's a lot to learn.  A lot
of choices.  You can make it
very, very full-featured
frontend web app with many
frameworks, JavaScript, it can
get complicated.  There's down
sides to that.  This might be
you if you're spending a lot of
time learning new technologies,
maintaining a complicated app,
trying to follow all your
callbacks, going through the
code, trying to do various
tweaks to get things to perform
better.  And speaking of
performance, unfortunately for
your convenience as a developer,
the user pays a price.  So
notice how web apps have gotten
bigger in the last six years.
Tripled  in size.  Images,
video.  But also JavaScript has
gotten very, very big.  Do you
have a site that has right now
15, 20, maybe 30 JavaScript
files on it?  400K of
JavaScript?  Maybe some large
frameworks that are loading
before anything else happens?
Using up CPU and battery power?
It takes a lot of
time for a good web app.  Was
thinking about this walking
around the city.  This is a
picture I took in Krakow.
There's music that's supposed to
be  playing.  There it is.
Mozart.  Why am I playing Mozart
at a web developer's
conference?  It reminded me of
the movie, Amadeus.  It reminded
me of that.  I showed this
every year when I was a music
teacher, otherwise they couldn't
stand classical music.  I was
thinking about elegance and
beauty.  And it was quieter, and
then louder and louder.
Elegant, beautiful things are
important.  They endure.
Simplicity is good.  When things
are simple, they're
maintainable for users.
Elegance means fewer bugs.   In
five years, your code will still
work.  Simplicity and elegance
matters.  Isn't one of the goals
of life making something
beautiful?  This is a goal also
of this PWA AMP pattern.  Making
things beautiful and simple and
elegant again on the web.
If web is too hard, can I make
an app instead?  Wouldn't that
be easier?  If you saw Sam's
talk, you would know all the
time is in major apps, Gmail,
Facebook, what's app.  If you're
making an app, chances are
small people will use it or
download it.  The average number
of apps a user installed in a
month is zero.  So the web is
pretty important on mobile
phones and will not go away any
time soon.
So make a simple Website.
That's not going to work.  Users
expect something better today.
They want a real web app
experience.  What do we do?
Like a baby, we can cry.  Or
maybe there's an easier way?
Happy baby.  Is there one?
There's not.   Okay.  Thanks a
lot, guys.  Wait, wait, wait.  I
have more slides to show.  I'm
just kidding.  I think the
easier way here is PWA and AMP.
What is that?  PWA you have
seen before in talks today,
provides app-like experience on
the web.  I won't go into this
in detail.  You have seen this
before.  But things load quickly
, they're engaging as a good app
would be.  They're quick, users
aren't waiting around, they
work offline.  All these things
people expect from mobile phone
experiences like they're on
messaging, like they're on
another app.  They want these
things also from a Website.  A
fast, good experience.
So what is AMP?  Accelerated
mobile pages.  People think of
it as a thing that was started
for publishers.  Most major
publishers in the world use AMP
in some way or another.  But
it's more than  that.  It's not
just for publishers.  It's not
just a way to make simple, light
web pages or to get into
Google's search AMP carousel,
it's a new pattern to make the
web easier and simpler and
faster for users and also for
all of you.
What is AMP?  A brief summary.
It's an ecosystem for fast,
beautiful responsive pages.  As
you heard earlier today, there's
over 2 billion  pages on the
web that use AMP.  Over a
million domains now use AMP.
AMP helps enforce good
performance and good looks.
It's basically a response to
bloat on the web.  It's making
things simpler, easier again.S
it doesn't cover all cases, but
it covers most cases.  Very few
web pages right now would lose
that much if converted to AMP.
Even though the first thing up
there, AMP allows you to write
no JavaScript.  No JavaScript at
all.  A little pause.  Probably
some people are crying.  People
are clapping.  Yes, you're
free!  You're  free.  You can
still use JavaScript, but not on
an AMP page.  It's already
there.  Because if you want
things that are interactive,
that are easy to use.  You want
things like an image carousel
where the images slide around on
the screen.  Users can't
understand these things, but
they're popular.  Or a
video embedded or a menu -- all
come with AMP.  That's the
second thing up there.  It's a
super-set with HTML.  Instead of
custom web components that do
those things that don't come
with HTML, but should.  HTML was
created for making documents,
not complicated web Apps.  With
AMP, you get everything back
from HTML.  You lose
flexibility, but you're coding
less.  You can code other
places.  And if you love CSS,
sorry to tell you this, it
restricts your CSS to 50K or
less.  Which, honestly, is
enough formost pages out there.
Probably all pages.  The idea
behind all these things, no
JavaScript web components and
less CSS is to make the pages
faster.  So they tend to load on
3G connections in a second, 2
seconds.  Which users like quite
a bit and which makes your
companies money.  It's good.
And don't forget the elegance
thing as well.  Your pages --
your code -- is more beautiful.
It's simpler.  You're not
trying to reinvent the wheel.
The wheel is already there for
you as part of AMP.  This had
sounds kind of hard, right?
I've got to learn two new
things.  PWA and AMP?  I can't
do  that.  I don't have time.
Actually, it's not as hard as it
sounds.
And to prove that, we have
created a simple example called
the shadow reader.  Whenever I
say shadow, I'll say it like the
up to face over here.  The
shadow reader.  Because I have
no shame.  Let's say you work
for a major news publisher and
you have a Website that's out
there.  But the boss knows that
people want to use a web app.
They're sick of the Website.
Stick of the pages.  He wants a
news  reader app.  So your
assignment from this
stern-looking boss over here --
you're the person with the hat
-- is to make a web app out of
existing web pages.  The site
already uses AMP.  So how do we
do that?  How do we take things
that already exist, those AMP
pages, and get those into a nice
,  immersive progressive web
experience?  Well, PWA with AMP
is your answer.  So why are AMPs
useful in a progressive web app
context?  Let's describe ways
that AMP can be used that hasn't
been used so far.  But starting
to be used now and play on the
strengths
of the web components library.
First, how AMP can be used as
web components, second as rich
data.  And third, AMP pages can
be portable,  embeddable content
units that you can embed in
other pages thanks to the magic
of shadow DOM.
I love that name, shadow DOM.
First of all, AMP as web
components.  This actually is
kind of obvious.  AMP is really
a library of web components.
Here are some examples of those
things over here.  Let's say you
want to make one of those
lovely image sliders that users
tend to object to, but people
love these things.  And there it
is.  That's an entire carousel.
That's done.  So AMP carousel,
you must specify width and
height.  The pages are laid out
in advance.  As they load, the
pages shift around.  So all of
your dimensions for images, ads,
everything else, are specified
in advance.  And there is a
couple of images.  The AMP image
tag.  And you're done.  There
it is.  Your carousel.  Things
lazy load.  It's all good.
You're done.
Number two, AMP as rich data.
This is kind of a weirder idea,
but kind of a cool idea once you
get the idea.  Idea.  It's a
good word to say several times
in a row.  AMP as rich data.
Often when  making your web app,
you have a shell and loading in
JSON and converting in JSON to
HTML using template, some kind
of logic.  This can be a
fragile, difficult process.  So
instead of doing that, you can
use HTML itself as the data.
It's a rich data source that
includes layout information,
includes components.  It's like
a whole page layout.  It's kind
of like markdown steroids.  It's
kind of this really powerful,
rich dataset.  So what I mean by
that -- here's a typical
example.  Say you have an
article on your web app that
you're making over  here, and
they aren't very good.  You have
an article about that, usual
data sources.  Data, whatever.
On the bottom here, maybe you
have an image of a guitar.
Maybe you have H2, a link.
Maybe you have an ad in there.
This is like data.
So you can pull this in to your
web app.  Which goes along with
the idea that AMP can be
portable, embeddable content
units.  So you can grab some
part of a page which is AMP and
stick it into your progressive
web app.  So, again, taking an
AMP page or some AMP stuff and
using that in a different
application.
So you could actually take your
web pages already that exist and
cram those things into a web
app.  And here you are with your
hat thinking, oh, here is the
key to my project over here.  I
don't have much time.  I can use
this pattern, taking our
existing app pages and putting
them with our new, immersive PWA
.  But how?  The first key is
the magic of shadow DOM.  Shadow
DOM is simple, it's kind of
cool and magical.  It's a DOM
sub tree that's fully
encapsulated inside an HTML
element.  All the HTML and CSS
is living inside elements in
fact DOM.  Shadow DOM.  It's
part of the web components idea.
And AMP comes in a version
called shadow AMP, which allows
entirely valid accelerated
mobile page to exist inside
another page.  This allows you
to AMP just one subsection of
the web page which we're going
to need in our app we're making
today.
How does this work?  On the top
over there you see we're loading
up not the usual AMP library,
but the shadow AMP library.  And
then on the bottom you see
we're going to actually -- once
AMP exists -- we're just going
to attach shadow doc over there.
Three arguments.  The
container where the shadow root
should be, the document itself,
and the URL from which the
document came originally.  The
complicated thing is this is
loaded asynchronous.  So you
can't call attached shadow doc
until it's loaded.  So we use
this
asynchronous callback pattern
to do that.  You see in the
middle that function means AMP
ready, takes the callback, and
simply looks for a global called
"AMP."  If that global already
exists, it adds that callback to
an array of callbacks.  If it
doesn't exist, it defines that
empty array.  So this way, as
AMP is still  loading, you can
keep on calling callback to the
object.  When it loads up, then
it calls back and then it runs
everything.  It may sound
complicated,
but it actually isn't that
complicated.  I'll say it simply
with fewer words.  You load the
shadow AMP asynchronous.  Once
it's loaded, you can use the
attached shadow doc message to
attach the AMP document
somewhere inside an existing
page.
Let's take a look at this now
because it's  getting pretty
abstract.  Let's go over to demo
over here and -- interesting.
Might have been logged out
during this time.  It's back.
This is the shadow reader.  Here
it is.  In this case it uses
The  Guardian as the backend.
The news is kind of depressing
today.  Sorry for that.  There's
two modes.  The cards mode.
Shows stop stories as a series
of cards.  And clicking into a
card, look for one that's not
bad and scary.  Here we go.  A
black hole.  That's kind of
cool.  It's not scary yet.
Clicking on that, you see a bit
of animation and it pops out and
there's the article mode.  It's
like the mode of this
application.  There it is.
Enormous black hole.  Not a
problem for a long time as far
as we can tell.  And by the way,
this bottom over here is all
the AMP page.  That's all AMP.
If you go back over here, you're
back here.  There are sections.
And so on.  If you look at
this here, we can see with HTML,
which is very small,
unfortunately, if you can see
this -- the very bottom, there's
a thing called "Article" over
here.  And if somewhere in
there, if you can see it, this
is called" Shadow root."  And in
there is an entire AMP page
just hiding in there.  And
there's the  body.  All the
content there on the shadow
root.  I know this is very hard
to see.  But try it out.
AMP.card is out there.  It's
public.  You can use  it.  Check
this out.  The code is out
there too.  Check it out.  See
how it's built.  Let's go back
to the slides now.  We're going
to
talk about more about how this
thing is built.
How is this thing built?  As we
discussed already before,
there's your AMP page.  Let me
move then to the PWA.  That's
the real key.  And three things
happen.  The first thing is the
AMP content gets pulled in from
the RSS feed.  And then we
inject the HTML right into the
DOM.  And then around all that
is the progressive web app
making this  nice, immersive
experience we were talking about
here.  Here's the first step.
Not that complicated.  Pull the
AMP content in from the feed and
you can see we use good old XHR
over here.  You can use fetch,
but the response to HTML is
actually a parsed DOM here.
Once you have this back, you
have the document object.  You
can tick that right into the DOM
of the page.  This is very
convenient.  And we're going to
remove parts we're not going to
move here.  On the top, for
example, the guardian doesn't
have the header.  We don't want
to see this as part of the app
experience.  Remove things from
the DOM you don't want.  Take
out side bars
and headers.  Just leave what
you need.  Step two, inject the
AMP HTML into the DOM.  Use the
shadow root and use the doc to
take the AMP document and stick
it right there into the shadow
DOM.
And then all around that is a
nice progressive web app which
has the kind of features you
want from progressive web apps.
It loads quickly with an app
shell.  As the app moves around,
as you go through the app,
things are loading quickly.  The
experience is immersive
throughout, like an app would
be.  You have the possibility of
on Android adding to the home
screen.  And an app-like
display, taking away the whole
URL bar.  And content is
available also offline.  How do
those things work?
Quickly, the first thing,
initial load is simple.  Let me
show you again.  If I can get
back to the computer here.
There's an actual original
payload that comes with this.  A
lot of CSS.  The HTML is pretty
simple.  A couple of things
here and then notice as we go
along here -- see if I can zoom
there a little bit -- you see
the little tildes other there.
See those things?  If you use
Facebook, loading your feed, and
the things that are resembling
things in your feed.  It gives
the user the impression things
are loading when they're not
there quite yet.  Users like
that if it's partially loaded
and they can see it load.  This
is like that, but pure text.  So
before any loading at all, you
have something that kind of
resembles how the app is going
to look.  A set of lovely
tildes.  Let's go back now to
the slides, please.  Thank you
very  much.
So -- yeah.  Simple, simple
initial load over there.  And
that thing at the top over there
is so it can know whether it's
actually from the URL in cards
mode or article mode and apply
the right kind of UI skeleton so
you have that nice kind of
loading in the beginning.
And then, of course, as the app
moves along, things move faster.
As you have AMP pages, AMP
pages load fast.  They're
simple.  And you use ShadowDOM
to get those things into your
PWA.  Then the immersive
experience is easy to do.  I'm
going to go back to the demo
here one last time.  We can see
these lovely animations over
here.  Again, this is just a
normal web app, so you can make
it nicely happen.  You click on
this black hole over here.  It
animates leftwards nicely.
Change articles.  Things merge
around smoothly.  There's stuff
for accessibility, for screen
readers, all those things you
need to do because you have all
the PowerShell of PWAs and CSS
and all those things.  Again,
try it out yourselves at home if
you would like to.  Let's get
back to the slides.  This is
easy for the PWA, you have the
manifests.  For Android, the
icons let you add things to the
screen -- the home screen, that
is.  And display stand alone
just tells Android to display
the app in a full
immersive-like app experience.
This part is super-simple.
Finally, offline content.  This
can be challenging when you do
service worker.  The caching
might be complicated sometimes.
It involves coding, some
promises, things like that.  But
in this case, it was simple.
We used Workbox as a work
around.  Throwing out Workbox JS
.  This was the only library
used in the making of this had
whole web app.  No Angular, no
React.  Not even jQuery.  The
code here is incredibly small to
make this happen.  In fact,
minimize is about 10K of
JavaScript behind the  scenes.
That's it.  About 10K.  Workbox
makes it simple.  Here is the
lovely cache for the queries.
You set your route, declare your
strategy, and you're all done.
The service worker has maybe 30
lines of code.  So there's
offline content.  We also
pre-cache some things like
images, other things that are
important for the app.
Like I was just saying a minute
ago, there was no framework used
in the making of this app.  Not
even jQuery.  These are samples
from the code.  A little bit
ponderous in some cases.
Document.query selector, all
these things., jQuery makes it
simply, but this is to show you
didn't need jQuery for this.
It's pretty simple.  It's just
JavaScript.  But not much
JavaScript.  A little bit like
the old days.
So this is good.  The web app.
The boss likes you.  You can
keep your job.  Triumph.
Happiness.  All those things.
So you're happy, then you think,
great, I have made this awesome
PWA, but is this  AMP, though?
I thought this AMP thing was
important because I have to get
into Google's search carousel
and the app cache and make
Google happy in some way.  This
is not an AMP over here.  I have
made a normal web page.  Is
that okay?  Can I do that?  And
--  yes, you can.  Who cares?
Go ahead and do it.
In this case, main app would not
pass AMP validation -- it isn't
supposed to -- but it's fast
and uses AMP.  It works really,
really well.  If you want to get
the Google AMP cache in the
first page, there's a pattern
for that.  The first page is
AMP -- the landing page can be
AMPed.  And
they have an install service
worker component.  You can
install service worker behind
the scenes, and then go to the
next, PWA, and then AMP behind
that again.  You can use these
in various ways to get the
benefits of AMP.  Pre-rendering
and finding the link in Google
search or elsewhere with the AMP
cache.  And PWA starts up, you
can use AMP components to make
your life easier.  And same with
publishing, and applies in
other kinds of ways.  What if
you have a site that's like a
lead Gen site.  Long form, five
different screens were your
name, address, birthday,
neighbor's name, dog's name,
cat's name, the name of the tree
in your front art.  All those
things.  This
happens sometimes.  With your
users -- if you use AMP, comes
with nice, formulated form
fields.  And like with the
articles, instead of  pages of
articles, you control the form.
You control the experience.
Users can't stand it when they
fill out a form and face a long
load.  In the PWA things can
load more quickly.  Especially
if they're AMP.  You can go back
and forth, you can control the
screen.  Make it fun for the
user to fill out this long form.
Register now.
Anotherred
another idea, E-commerce.
Various E-commerce sites are
using AMP for all sorts of
things, product pages, listing
pages.  And up to and including
the checkout process.  It's
possible with AMP.  That's the
payment request API.  So in this
case, I imagine instead of your
news articles, a series of
product pages all written with
AMP so they're fast.  Users are
getting around to actually have
things loaded.  And dynamic
content is possible with AMP as
well.  There's AMP state, AMP
list, various components that
let you change things on the
screen dynamically.  So you
change the number of things
you're buying,  prices can
change, shipping costs can
change with user input and so on
and so forth.  Or imagine the
travel application.  Instead of
articles, you have hotel.  Hotel
information.  And you go back
to  hotels.
So, again, all possible with AMP
in a PWA context.  The upshot
is this makes you money.
Because the users are happy
because they have a better
experience.  They're not
abandoning the pages as much.
And a lot of data show us AMP
pages tend to get better user
engagement.  Data shows that
faster pages get better user
engagement, better conversions,
lower bounce.  So the users are
staying on for longer on your
app and they're converting.
They're buying something, or
they're viewing an ad.  Whatever
it is.  Ad support in AMP is
also very advanced these days so
you're getting money from the
users.  You also make money
because developers are spending
less time working on their app.
Things are simpler for them.
So you can make things more
quickly.  So you make money on
both sides of the coin.
Which, of course, isn't your
motivation because you're
programmers.  You don't care
about the money.  You care about
the duty of your code.  The
integrity of your work.  Money
is one of those things that gets
you rent and maybe occasional
Doritos or soup.  Or
kielbasa and
dumpings over here.  It's not
just because of the money you're
making and retiring early or
becoming a manager, you didn't
create this terrible
Frankenstein web app was that
hodgepodge of stuff you found on
the Internet and copied and
pasted them together.  You don't
have to panic.  This is
something in old town as well.
Instead, you have a lovely,
maintainable, elegant code
that's going to work for longer.
That people will like in a
couple years.  Future
programmers at your company will
see your code and smile instead
of thinking, why did they make
all this stuff?  It's crazy.  It
looks easy, it's elegant and
maintainable.  And the
conclusion -- isn't life about
creating
something beautiful?  This is
your chance to do that.  PWA and
AMP.  Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> I'll wait for you to settle
down.
Hi, everyone.  My name is
Shailen Tuli
.  I'm a developer program
engineer working on Android at
Google.  And I'm here to talk to
you about building great apps.
Android O.  Android O is kind
of a big topic.  There are lots
of cool things in O.  And
there's a talk later in the
afternoon that's going to cover
many of them.  My talk is going
to talk about -- it's going to
focus on a couple of topics.
Basically what you can and
cannot do with regard to
background work in your O apps.
And what you can and cannot do
with regard to location
gathering when your app is in
the background.  This is going
to be a fairly technical talk.
I'm going to focus on just those
two issues.
And I have a lot of material, so
I'm going to go a little fast.
So you have been warned.  Okay.
So why focus on background so
much?  Why focus on background
limits coming in O and the
location  limits?  Because first
I believe these are some of the
biggest changes in the
platform.  And these are changes
that have really, really great
consequences to you app
developers because I believe
these  changes make Android an
even better platform for writing
apps.
So that's what I'm going to be
focusing on.  I'll talk, of
course, about what the changes
are.  What strategies you can
use to deal with them.  I'll
talk a little bit about
historically how we got to this
point where we have to limit
what kind of background work
goes on generally and
specifically with regard to
location.  So sort of a little
historical overview of things.
Okay.  So pretty much everything
I'm going to cover in this
talk, system health, basically
good RAM management, or battery.
So how to get more battery
performant stuff happening in
your apps.  What I'll do is
start with a little overview and
just talk about a few things
that gives you a sense of what's
happening in O.  And then a
deep dive into each of these
topics afterwards.
So the first thing in regards to
system health is there is a
limitation in O that there will
be no startup services in the
background.  This is kind of a
big deal.  But it really only
applies to startup services in
the background.  In the
foreground, you can keep doing
what you're doing now.  The
other system health issue is
that there will be fairly
substantial limits on implicit
broadcasts.  So you can still
have explicit broadcasts, you
can  dynamically register for
broadcasts, but broadcasts that
go into your manifest, there are
going to be quite a lot of
limits based on those.  Again
, we'll explore these.  So the
question is, when?  When do all
these things happen?  When do
you have to worry about these
things?  The answer is when you
implement your target SDK
version for target O.  That
means distant to some people,
maybe not so distant to others.
But I would urge everyone to
start thinking about this and
thinking about it now, because
even today users of your
apps can go into the settings of
their phones, figure out how
much work they're doing in the
background, decide if that work
is too much and essentially
curtail that work.
So like it or not, the limits on
background work that you can
do, those are here already.  So
it's something that you, as app
developers, kind of have to deal
with.  You'll deal with it much
more substantially when you
upgrade to O, but you have to
deal with them now as well.
That's system health.  And let's
talk about the battery now.
That's the focus of the changes
coming in O.  So basically
what's happening is that for
battery reasons, what kind of
location gathering you can do in
the background is going to be
substantially throttled.  So if
you have gotten use to the idea
of having very frequent updates,
for instance, in the foreground
and in the background, the
foreground stuff is going to
remain the same.  The background
stuff will be quite different.
So the question is, when does
this kick in?  When do these
limits kick in?  And the answer
is they kick in now.  For any
app running on an O device,
regardless of SDK version, the
limits are here.  If you have an
app that does something with
location and the target is M or
L, that app actually behaves
quite differently without you
having to change a leadership of
code.  That app when it's run
on an O device is going to
behave differently.  Could
behave differently.  This is a
fairly significant change as
well.  If you have a location
component to your apps, you are
going to have to deal with.
So these are big changes.  No
startup services, limits on what
you can do with broadcasts,
limits to what you can do with
the background.  So the question
is, why are we doing this?  How
did we get here?  What's really
going on?  So the first thing
is, we're not doing this because
we like being difficult or we
just like making people's lives
difficult.  We're doing this
because this is essentially
better for the platform.  It's
better for the users.  The users
want us to build -- want you --
to build apps that are really,
really important.  That do
really great things with RAM
management.  That do really
great things with battery.  The
changes that we've introduced in
O have been a long time in the
coming.  So I'm going to get to
all the details in a minute or
two.  But I'm going to take it
and talk about how we got here
starting in Marshmallow.  So go
back to Marshmallow.  That's
when we introduced Doze.  So
what's Doze?  Just a recap, when
your device is stationary, not
charging, and the screen is off
-- essentially when it's not
being used -- we said you can't
go crazy and do all sorts of
things in the background.  You
have to channel your background
work into  well-defined
maintenance windows.  When a
device is sitting there, it
should not be doing crazy things
.  It should be a quiet machine.
That's where those came in.
Android M also gave us app
standby.  And the idea is if you
have background network
activity, how that activity was
done was actually dependent on
how much or how little the user
was interacting with your app.
Again, the idea is if there's
background work being done,
let's do this very carefully.
And in Android N, we gave you
Doze Light, like Doze, but the
difference is the device is not
stationary.  Think of I have my
phone right here.  It's not on.
Obviously, it's not charging.
But it's moving because I'm
moving.  And, again, the idea
was -- even then -- you do
background work pretty
carefully.
So all of this started off a
couple of releases ago, and what
you are seeing in O is pretty
much a very natural progression
for what we introduced in M and
in N.  So the other stuff that's
very significant is -- starting
in N -- we started paying
attention to some broadcasts
that we felt were excessively
noisy, that were causing system
health problems, crashing.  Very
visible jank for users.  And we
decided to curtail what you
could do with those broadcasts.
So in Android N we said, for
instance, the connection action
broadcast.  You could not listen
to this in the register.  And
you could no longer register for
this in your  management.
And the reason was that it was
an extremely noisy broadcast.
We didn't want you waking up
apps, doing connective lead
changes -- it was too expensive.
Similarly, there were two
other broadcasts that were
targeted in N.  And that's
action new picture, action new
video.  These are fired when a
user takes a picture or creates
a little video.  And so this is
-- action new picture is
actually a great example to
consider when you think about
what the system health
implications are of allowing a
broadcast like that to happen.
So imagine a user takes out
their phone, takes a photograph.
At that point, there are --
let's  say -- 20 apps on the
user's device which have
registered for this broadcast.
The system says, all right!
Let's go!  Let's wake you up.
Off you go.  One, two, three,
four, five.  And each of those
apps all wants to do great,
impressive things.  What
doesn'tment to impress the user,
right?  They start services and
expensive stuff.  Before you
know, the system is saying, hey,
apps, seven, eight -- I can't
start you until I kill one, two,
three.  It's turbulent, it's
launching stuff, creating stuff,
killing stuff, doing whatever
it can.  Heaven forbid the user
takes a second or a third
picture -- even more crazy.  In
Android N we said this is no way
for an operating system to be
behaving.  You cannot write this
in the manifest.  We're to the
going crazy every time somebody
takes a picture.  So that's the
background of that.  Modify now,
the location stuff that we're
going
to talk about is largely due to
batteries.  And battery has been
a huge issue for us year after
year.  In our surveys,
developers tell us -- the users
tell us -- sorry -- one in three
people saw that battery is the
number one concern for them
about Android.
And what happens is users --
rightly or  wrongly -- associate
location with battery drain.
And because they do that, they
go and disable location all
together, which makes all the
nice apps you guys have written
not work at all.  Or they work
in a degraded manner.  This is
not good for the app developer.
It's not good for the user.
It's not good for Android as a
platform.  So this time in O
Google has taken a very serious
approach to battery management
.  And targeted background of
location as a primary which
needs to be carefully managed
for battery to work well.
All right.  So that's the
historical stuff.  One more
little segue before we
dive into it.  All through this
time, we are talking about
startup services, implicit
broadcasts, location.  And it's
a good thing to take a minute
and say what exactly is
foreground?  What exactly is
background.  It's sort of
obvious at one level, maybe not
so obvious at another.  So the
obvious stuff.  When you have a
visible app component -- when
the user can see your app, when
your activity is started or
resumed, you're in the
foreground.  When you have a
widget, you're in the foreground
.  Fairly obvious.  When you
have a foreground service, you
are considered foreground.  Kind
of obvious.  It's a foreground
service.  Knowing the foreground
-- stay with the foreground.
You are in the foreground with a
foreground service.  When you
have a bound service and there
is a client in the foreground
binding to that service, you are
then also in the foreground.
When you have a content provider
and there
is something that is in the
foreground accessing the content
provider, you are, then, also
in the foreground.
And then there's a slew of sort
of very  specialized cases which
-- if you read about  these --
you will understand, yeah, these
have to be foreground.  An
accessibility service, for
instance, has to perform all
sorts of actions on behalf of
the user.  It has to be
considered foreground.
Notification, listener service,
indicator, wall paper service.
You can find documentation on
developer.android.com explaining
all of this pretty carefully.
The good news is, in all of
these cases that I mentioned,
nothing that relates to
background limit for Android.
If you're in the foreground, you
can pretty much do whatever you
could do in any release up
until now.  Nothing really
changes for you.  But when are
you now not in the foreground?
When are you in the background?
No visible app component.
You're stuck.  There's no widget
.  You brought in a started
service that is not a foreground
service.  That will put you in
the background.  You are in a
job service.  We'll be talking
about jobs later on.  But when
you're in that part of the code,
you are, again, going to be in
the background.  And when you
are dealing with the broadcast
inside your broadcast
receiver,ing you also, this time
, are in the background.  In all
of these cases the background
limits that have been introduced
, they will apply.
So it's kind of a big deal.
Trivial apps can do without
dealing with broadcasts and
services, et cetera.  Most
people don't write trivial apps.
They write mature apps.  Those
apps will be affected by these
changes.  So I'm going to dive
into services and what's
changing with services in
Android O.  Lots of fun stuff.
As I said, this is a pretty
technical talk, so we will go
deep into this.
From now on applications can no
longer freely execute background
services.  So the idea is we
want you to stop thinking of our
services and start thinking
about jobs.  The jobs get you
there, fire this job, for the
kind of work that you would
currently give to services.
Apps that are doing ongoing work
with regard to broadcasts
should also start thinking about
jobs.  Because, you know,
starting a service, for
instance, to do something in
response to a broadcast will no
longer be possible.
The idea of these changes is
fundamentally, it's expensive
work, or potentially expensive
is being done on behalf of the
user, the user should be aware
of that.  It should be visible
to the user.  If you are doing
things that cost the user
battery, RAM, whatever, are the
user should sort of say, hey, I
know you're doing this.  I
approve.  This is  making my app
experience good.  We don't want
work being done quietly in a
less than December tin manner
without the approval.  That's
the
guiding principle behind the
changes.  If you do it in the
foreground, illegal
state exception.  If it's
pending, it won't work.  You
will get a log warning.
Basically there isn't a way --
when you're in the background --
to start service anymore.
So this is pretty -- this is
kind of a big  deal.  I don't
know if you'll think it's a big
deal.  But when I first found
out about this, I said, whoa.
That's a big deal.  But there
are actually some very practical
ways in which this is softened
up.  One is that there is a
grace period.  So services
continue to run on for a while
once you lose your foreground
status.  So take an example of
you have an app.  The app does
some -- the user is using the
app.  It launches a service.
Service is doing fine.  And then
the user swipes away your app.
It's gone now.  It's no longer
in the foreground.  The service
won't be cut off immediately.
There will be a few minutes of
grace period where the service
will continue to run, at which
point the system will step in
and say, okay, enough of that.
Get off of the service.  And
effectively what will happen in
a few minutes is the services
will be called and it will be as
if the services are called stop
self.  The system will just do
that for
you.
But, it's nice that it's not
abrupt.  There is a grace
period.  The second is I think
the realization that sometimes
when you are in the background,
your app is going to want to
respond to certain events.  They
may be very user-visible
events, other kinds of events.
There's a process to temporarily
wait list Apps.  To keep
apps as if they're in the
foreground.  This is best
explained with examples.  Say
you have a high priority cloud
message coming down to your
device.  It sees the
restrictions and your app wants
to do something with it.  We
give you a period of a few
seconds -- less than a minute --
where by you can be considered
foreground and launch services.
Similarly, if you have an SMS
delivery, you may want to
respond to that.  There's a
short window where you're given
temporary foreground status and
you can respond to that.
And in Android O, notifications
are kind of a big deal.  When
you are responding to a
notification action at any time,
and there's a pending intent
involved, at that point you are
treated as if you are in the
foreground.  This is a very
pragmatic approach the framework
team has taken.  By and  large,
we don't want to do any
expensive work in the background
.  But we understand there are
some cases where you'll need to
do it, and here's how you do
it.  So this
whitelisting process should
impact -- help most developers
target what they need to do
pretty effectively.  That's our
hope.  Foreground services are
not affected by any of this.  So
you can have a foreground
service, have a persistent
notification.  The user sees
that -- life is good.  The only
problem is that foreground
services have typically within
done in two steps.  Start a
service in the background and
then promote it to foreground.
The first part is not going to
work anymore.  You can't start
services in the
background.  There's a new API
for starting foreground
services.  It just does it for
you.
We'll talk more about foreground
services at the appropriateness
of foreground services in a
bit.  So a question I was asked
when I did this presentation in
India by a developer, do you
expose an API where I can tell
if it's safe to start service or
not?  No, we do not.  It's for
the app developer to figure out
when it's safe or not safe to
start a service.  Essentially,
you have to figure out when
you're in the foreground and not
in the foreground and go with
that.  So that's the gist of the
services part.  A couple other
points to tidy  up, bound
services are unchanged.
Because we're thinking much more
about foreground and background
, there are some semantics of
this that are interesting.  So,
for instance, if I am bounding
-- if I'm in the foreground and
I'm binding to one of my own
services, that's no big deal.
If I'm not foreground and I'm
binding to somebody else's
service and they're in the
background, then they, too, will
be considered foreground.
Because a foreground client
elevates their status to
foreground as well.
So these are sort of things that
, as you start thinking in sort
of all semantics, in all terms
much more, will be very obvious.
It's not what I was thinking
about when I was writing code.
This is going to be a little bit
of an adjustment as we go into
O.  All right.  Here we go.
Question that's asked of me,
what about intent services?  You
have talked about startup
services, what about intent
services?  They are startup
services.  Everything I have
said about startup services
applies to them.  In fact, this
is kind of a big deal.  So the
support library now has service
for the jobintentservice and
could be considered a
replacement for intentservice.
We'll talk about this in a
minute.  Fundamentally we would
like to start thinking that jobs
are the way we want to go about
this.  Services, expensive
broadcasts, are really -- have
served us well and worked well
up until O.  But from now on job
scheduler, job dispatcher and
jobs are a real Swiss Army Knife
as you go forward building
your apps.
So that's services.  A lot of
stuff to take in.  A lot of
changes.  So I'm going to throw
more stuff at you now.
Background limits and
broadcasts.  So the limitation
is on implicit broadcasts and
the gist of it is that limits to
implicit broadcasts delivered
to manifest and find reviewers
are not going to be honored for
the most part.
So at this point, the question
comes -- what is an explicit
broadcast?  An compliment
broadcast?  You'll see confusing
answers about that.  The answer
is if a broadcast is explicitly
targeted at someone, something,
a target, an app, then you can
put it in the manifest.  If it
is not a broadcast sent out into
the wild, it's compliment,
don't put in the manifest.
Take, for example, action
package  replaced.  If you
register for this before O in N
and lower, you will have this
broadcast go off every time any
package is placed on your
device.  That's pretty
noisy, right?
In contrast, my package replace.
This package is sent only to
me because my package has been
replaced.  So this is kind of a
big distinction.  It's not
always incredibly intuitive.
But this is something that
developers would have to think
about.  Explicit broadcasts can
still be put in the  manifest,
no problem.  Now, there are some
implicit broadcasts that the
framework team know need to be
allowed.  If you follow these,
there's a good reason why each
one of these is permitted to be
put in O in your manifest.  So
action boot completed.  This
fires once.  It's required by
apps to set up jobs, et cetera,
et cetera.  It's not hugely
disruptive.  It's okay.  Action
locale changed.  Well, your
locale presumably doesn't change
a whole lot, and when it does,
it's not unreasonable that apps
will want to respond to that.
Action headset plug.  The user
plugs in their headset.  So at
that point does the user --
they're involved.  And some app
may want
to respond to that.  This is not
hugely disruptive.  When you
have SMS, you want to respond.
This is a partial list.  The
whole documentation is there on
Android.developer.com.  And it
will explain to you where all
these broadcasts -- while
they're  implicit, are
completely okay.
The dynamic registration for
broadcast is completely okay.
Nothing of this has changed.  So
you can always use context or
register receiver, and long as
the context is valid, you'll get
whatever broadcast is
registered here.  That's
completely okay.  It's not
changed.  The idea is if the app
is used with a context, it's
not hugely disruptive to get the
broadcast.  If your app is
asleep, that's a different
thing.
So that's the way to think about
these limitations that are
being used.  So at this point
you're thinking, well, this is
fantastic for developer -- for
users, right?  Your battery is
preserved, your system health is
so much better.  No long-
running services.  All the noise
generated by these broadcasts,
that's pretty much quite a down.
What about me?  The developer?
I had great ideas and plans.
What am I supposed to do?  So
let's talk a little bit about
that.  What you can do is a
bunch of strategies.  So first,
instead of having  long-running
services, if there is some
stimulus that changes something
in your app or that wants to
change something in your app,
use cloud messaging.  It's
fantastic.  Use cloud messaging.
If you use high priority it
will pierce through those.  It
will give you temporary
foreground status and you're
good to go.  If you use normal
priority, that's still very good
because now the operating
system can judiciously,
carefully, efficiently
schedule the work that you want
to do.  Normal priority should
be your default.  You don't want
to abuse this.  You want to
preserve the system health that
comes from that.
Another thing is that
restructure use
jobintentservice.  I mentioned
that a few slides  ago.
Jobintentservice is part of the
support library.  It's very new.
It should be considered a
replacement for intentservice.
It's aware of background limits
and it will do the right thing.
In the apps, it will run
context.service.  And O and
beyond O apps, it will run job
scheduler for work.  This is a
pretty good way to have all that
abstracted away and you don't
have to think about  it.
Wakefulbroadcastreceiver is
deprecated.  The whole point was
that you're handling a
broadcast when you kick off a
service or something like that.
You can't do that anymore,
there's really no reason to have
this sticking around.
And finally
-- and this is kind of an
important conceptual point --
you want the operating system to
be your friend, right?  So go
back to that example I gave of
somebody taking a picture and it
spins off the starting off of
10, 15, 20 apps.  All of which
are now starting services.  At
that point the operating system
can do one of two things: it can
either run your app, or it can
kill your app.  It can not do
anything else.  It will try to
run everything, but when it
loses the ability to run
everything, it kills it.  You
don't want the  operating system
to be turned into a killer.
You want to schedule -- your
work to be scheduled
intelligently by the operating
system.  So for that reason it's
much better
to use jobs.  When you use jobs
the operating system can say,
all right, one, two, three.  I
run you now.  Four, five -- run
you.  One again.  It can
schedule that intelligently.
You want to go for that.  We
encourage you to use job
scheduler as much as you can.
And the big topic topic: you can
use foreground services for
doing all sorts of great work
and there are no limits.  So a
very big temptation would say,
oh, my god, so much is changing
in O.  I'm going to slap on a
foreground service and I don't
have to think about this.  The
problem with that is the
foreground service has a certain
meaning.  When I'm listening to
music, I'm in a fitness app,
using maps and navigation, it
makes sense there's a
notification at the top and it's
doing work for me even when I'm
not actively engaging in the
app.  If that's the case in your
apps, use a foreground service.
It's a fantastic reason.  If
not, the user is going to say,
what the hell, there's a
notification at the top telling
them there's work being done.
They can stop the work or
uninstall your app.  Don't want
to happen.  If it doesn't make
sense, think of the other
strategies that we have outlined
and go with those.
And finally, since O is pretty
much putting you in a position
where you have to think about
background and what you're doing
in the background, I think it's
a good time to ask.  Do you
really need to do all this
background work?  I think there
has been a sense for many, many,
many years now in Android that
it's cool to just spin up
something and have it run
forever and ever in the
background and the system will
somehow handle it.  Now the
system is telling you, no, no.
We don't want to handle it.  We
don't want this to happen.  So
if we are really at the point
where we are questioning all
this, it's a good time to ask,
hey, I started doing all this
background work three years,
four years ago in my app, do I
really still need to do this?
The answer sometimes will be no.
You don't need to do this.  In
which case you shouldn't.
Fast segue to location.  So
first of all, location is kind
of a huge topic.  It's use ared
in a ton of apps.  In fact, when
I started looking  ating
at logs to see who was using
are location, I didn't through
all these apps were using
location.  But they are.  And in
Android O, the
location is significant.
People treat location as a
battery drain.  They turn off
location and your apps don't
work properly.  We believe this
doesn't help anyone.  We believe
that location should be used
wisely, efficiently.  It should
not be conflated
as an automatic battery drain.
We want people to love their
location apps, right?  So this
is where kind of big changes
have happened in O.  And you
will  see -- while this may seem
a little dramatic at first --
you can see how much better an
experience this would be going
forward for app developers.
So the location limits are the
background apps will receive
location in a very throttled
way.  So when you're in the
foreground, you can pretty much
request location -- I don't know
-- as often as you want.  Say
you want updates, you can have
location updates, 30 seconds,
whatever.  Once you go in the
background, we will give you
location updates a few times an
hour.  That's it.
So this is kind of a big deal.
And this will happen regardless
of the targeted version.  So on
your N apps, M apps, L apps --
whatever.  This will start
happening now the moment all
devices start appearing.  You
can use batching.  And what that
does, it collects location ever
so many times and delivers all
the location data to you in a
batched way.  And that's the way
that you can get more data
points.  You trade
trade latency for more data.
But the data will only be
delivered a few times an hour.
The changes in O and Wi-Fi
scanning.  So we could have an
entire talk about what makes
location expensive, what doesn't
make it expensive.  But GPS is
very expensive.  Super-accurate,
but very expensive.  Wi-Fi
isn't actually that cheap.  So
the deal is no location will be
-- when the device is at the
same static access point.
There's no need for it.  Your
location isn't changing.  We're
going to be judicious in making
Wi-Fi scans.  Because they're
expensive.
And this is good for a lot of
people.  For me, I spend, I
don't know, ten, 12, 15 hours at
home.  I'm connected to the
same Wi-Fi.  Why the hell does
location services have to
compute my location over and
over?  It's not changing.
Similarly when I'm at work and I
spend eight, ten, hopefully not
15 hours at work -- again, I'm
connected to the same Wi-Fi.
Nothing is changing.  Why does
location service have to expend
energies trying to compute my
location?  Most people spend a
lot of time at home or at work.
So there's a lot of changes to
Wi-Fi scanning that actually
make O much better.
There's also changes in O to how
geofencing works.  So it was
quite normal up until O to scan
for geofencing every few seconds
.  And we have now made that not
every few seconds, but around a
two minute latency.  This is
sort of big.  But what we
noticed is that even going from
tens of seconds to two minutes
for geofencing latency, it was
dramatic battery performance.
In some device, it was 10X.
It's device-dependent, so not
always 10X.  But it was
dramatic.  That's another piece
that's coming..  So up until now
everything I have said about
location is about what happens
when you run your M app, L app,
on an old device.  What happens
when you actually start
targeting O?  What happens to
location?
So the first thing is, you know,
we have always told you when
you request locations, use a
pending intent.getservice.
That's one of the arguments you
pass to your location request.
You can't do that anymore
because it's O.  There's no
getservice, background services
can't be started.  So you have
to have a different strategy.
And that strategy is you use
pendingintent.getbroadcast and
go and register an explicit
broadcast in your manifest and
that will work.  So the
targeting of O is not hugely
hard.  I think it will -- it
should be fairly  painless to do
it.  Getting adjusted to the
idea that you are running on O
when you hadn't planned to is
going to be an adjustment.  I
would urge all
of you to start thinking about
this task.
So what are good location
strategies?  What can you do as
developers now?  Frankly, the
location stuff -- these changes
are here now.  Sooner or later
all devices are going to start
running your
apps on those O devices, and
they will notice the location
works differently.  So a very
good  strategy, instead of
having long-running services or
expensive and very fast location
updates in the background, is
to start using geofencing much
more.  We have generally found
that people use geofencing less
than we would like them to.
Geofencing is  very, very, very
supremely
optimized for  performance.  I
have a geofence around the
Krakow airport and around the
airport I'll be flying to in a
couple of days in San Francisco,
location services knows there's
no reason for it to expend any
cycles trying to track
geofencing.  I'm not there.  But
it also knows I'm actually not
that far from the Krakow
airport.  It can very causally
and
judiciously monitor that.  So a
lot of the use cases for
location updates involve updates
around an area.  When am I near
home?  When am I near a
restaurant?  When am I leaving a
place?  Et cetera, et cetera.
And geofencing can be a huge,
huge asset.  So please use it as
much as you can.  Use batching.
I  promised to talk more about
batching.  So I'll do that now.
Essentially, what you're doing
is, when you're in the
background, you're only going to
get updates a few times an
hour.  But you can get more data
points as long as you're
prepared to give up the -- the
tradeoff is with latency.  So
look at this.  So you create a
location request.  You set  its
interval to be ten minutes.  So
say give my location updates
every ten minutes.  And then you
say, but deliver them no later
than 30 minutes.  So in a normal
situation, what will happen is
you will get three location data
points every 30 minutes in this
kind of a case.  If you didn't
set the max wait time, you would
not
get batching, and therefore you
would miss out on data points.
Another very, very important
location strategy in the age of
O is to get your location
passively.  So what are we
talking about here?  Basically,
location is computed on a device
basis.  Not just an app basis.
So when your app is in the
background, and therefore
getting fairly infrequent
location updates, another device
-- another app -- may be in the
foreground.  It may be a
mapping app or another app that
gets location updates quite a
lot.  Location services, free of
charge, will make that stuff
available to you -- the data
points available to you -- and
to any other app that's in the
background.  This kind of
opportunistic location gathering
I think is extremely good.
It's -- we believe it's
underutilized and we would like
developers to use it much more.
So here's an example how you
can do that.  Again, you create
a location request.  You set the
interval to ten minutes.  You
set the max wait time for
batching to 30 minutes.  Then
you set the fastest interval to,
let's say, two minutes.  Meaning
, if I'm in the background and
anybody else is consuming
location data, every couple of
minutes let me know about the
data.  And given the sheer
number of apps that use
location, there's a pretty good
chance that when the user is
using their phone or something
else, they will be gathering
location data and then you can
have it for free.
So that's a very important
strategy.  I would urge all of
you to use it.  While you're
down all this, you know, because
of these changes in O, we're
putting development in a
position where they kind of had
to rethink their location
strategies from scratch.  If
you're going to do that, think
of it for pre-O apps also.  If
you're running an N, M, or L
app, that too can use the same
principles put forward in O and
become more battery efficient.
Why wait?  You can start making
things better now.
So fundamentally location is
expensive in one of three ways
related to frequency, latency,
or accuracy.  So O is saying to
us on the frequency axis
, when you're in the background,
don't be so frequent.  You can
implement that now for your M
and N apps.  Again, latency.
Sometimes it's okay -- sometimes
you want the real-time
experience.  But sometimes it's
actually okay to wait a few
seconds before you get the
location data that has been
computed for you.  So use
batching, like we just talked
about.  You can do that now.  If
you're using geofence, you can
use a responsiveness time.  The
more you give it, the better
your battery performance will
be.  You can do all of these
things now for your apps.
And when you're at it, I mean, O
isn't really dealing with
accuracy that much.  If you're
rethinking everything in regards
to location, you might as well
say, do I really need high
accuracy all the time?  Maybe I
can use a balance power
accuracy, maybe no power.  There
are a lot of  options.  You can
read our documentation on this.
Do I need the best, greatest,
most expensive location updates
all the time?  Probably not.
And finally, foreground
services.  You can go right
ahead and just completely bypass
all these location limits in O
by running a foreground service.
But you just have to make sure
the user will really approve of
that service.  Otherwise they
will get annoyed with your app
and probably uninstall it.
Don't want that.
That's basically it.  A lot of
stuff.  I'm around if you have
apps that you think are going to
be now struggling with some of
these O limits, please come and
talk to me.  I would love to
hear your story.  And happy
coding.  Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Hello, everyone. Welcome to
machine  learning APIs by
example.  I'm going to teach you
how you can use pre-trained
APIs to access  pre-trained AI
models.  I'm Sara Robinson,
Srob Tweets.  I focus on then
in learning and big data.  I'm
based in New York.  This is my
first time in Poland.  Super-
computed to be here.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.  I'm going to talk
about what machine learning is.
At a high level, machine
learning is teaching computers
to recognize patterns in the way
that our brains do.  Over time,
as machine learning models are
given more examples and
experience, they can improve.
And with more data, able to
make better predictions.  It's
easy for a child to look at a
cat and a dog.  But it's much
more difficult to teach a
computer to do the same thing.
Pretend we don't have any
machine learning models or deep
neural networks.  And try  human
-powered image detection.  If we
were to write an algorithm to
differentiate between the two,
what are some things to look
for?  Shout it out.  I heard
color.  That's a good one.  So
for color, are the majority of
the pixels red?  If so, it's an
apple, otherwise it's an orange.
That would work pretty well in
this example.  But what if we
have gray scale images.  We have
to start over again.  Some
things so look for?  Stem,
texture.  We
could look at those qualities
and take us through the gray
scale images.  What if we got
crazy and added a mango to the
equation?  Then we start over.
You  getted why the.  They're
all similar.  They're fruit and
circular.  It would be a lot
easier with two images that look
nothing alike.  What if we have
a picture of a dog and a mop.
They have pretty much nothing in
common.  The mop is not living
or  breathing, no eyes, nose, or
ears.  It's actually kind of
difficult.
So here we have pictures of
sheep dogs and  mops, four of
each.  It's kind of hard, even
for the human eye, to be able to
distinguish between the  two.
So the point I'm trying make
here, what if we have photos of
everything?  We don't know what
photos our users in our
application might upload.  Might
not just be fruits or animals.
We'll have photos of all sorts
of things.  And in in addition
to photos, we might have other
types of unstructured data such
as video, audio were text.  And
on Google Cloud Platform, there
are two ways to make sense of
the sun structured data.  If you
want to build and train your
own machine learning from
scratch, we have TensorFlow.  If
you want to run it on managed
Google infrastructure, you can
use cloud machine learning
engine.  What I'm going to focus
on today is the right-hand
side.  This is what I like to
call friendly machine learning.
So these are APIs that give you
access to pre-trained models
with a single REST API request.
I'm
going to cover all these APIs in
the presentation.  And I'll
dive right in with the vision
API.  It's a complex image
request with a REST API rest.
First, companies that are using
it in production.  The example
on the left is Disney.  They use
a vision API for a game for
Pete's Dragon.  It was a
scavenger hunt-type game.  They
had to take a picture of an item
, a couch or a computer.  If
they took a picture of the item,
the app would superimpose
Elliott the dragon on the photo.
They needed to verify that the
user's image matched the clue
it was given, and the vision API
was a great fit for that.
Realtor.com is a real estate
service and use the recognition
feature to extract text.  So
when somebody is looking for
houses and they use the
Realtor.com app.  They can take
a picture of the for sale sign
and be immediately connected to
the correct listing.  They are
using the vision API to extract
the text and direct them to the
relevant listing.
These are the core features.
Label detection will tell you
what is this a picture of.  Face
detection will tell you, are
there faces in the image?  Where
are the faces located and what
are the different emotions?
Happy?  Sad?  Angry or
surprised?  I mentioned with
real
Realtor.com, and you can
extract the image.  And content
detection will tell you, is this
image appropriate or not?  And
this is useful for pretty much
any site with  user-generated
content.  So you can -- instead
of
having somebody manually review
the content, is it appropriate
or not?  You can send to the
APIs and only review a subset of
the images.  And landmark
detection and logo detection can
find company logos in an image.
To look at the responses.
Face detection.  This is a
selfie with two of my teammates.
We took this last year in
Jordan.  And face detection
returns an
object for each face it finds
on the image.  The JSON response
we see is just for my face.
Head wear, unlikely, I'm not
wearing a hat.  Both teammates
are.  And joy likelihood, very
likely.  I was excited, on
vacation, taking selfies.  And
returns data on where features
are.  And then if we look at
landmark detection, you can take
this picture of a common
landmark.  This is the Eiffel
tower, right?  It's actually not
the Eiffel tower.  It is the
Paris hotel and casino in Las
Vegas.  And I wanted to see if
the vision API could spot the
difference.  It could.  It
correctly identified this as the
Paris hotel and casino.  And
you'll notice that the MID and
the response.  The MID maps to
Google's knowledge graph.  If
you want more information on the
entity, send to the knowledge
graph API to get more
information on the Paris hotel
and casino.  We get a box of
where this is found, and the
latitude, longitudinal.  And
additional features in the
vision API, one is crop hints.
Suggested crop dimensions for
the photo.  Web annotations,
search the at the time had for
details on your image.  And I'll
get into that more.  And
document text annotations
improves the OCR model for the
APIs.  So it's easier to
identify large blocks of text.
If you have an image
of a menu or business card, it
can break it down into words and
symbols.  I want to focus more
on the web annotations.  And to
do that, I have this image of a
car.  It's not just any car.
It's the car from the Harry
Potter movies.  I'm a big Harry
Potter fan and it's on display
in a museum.  This is the car
from the second movie.  I wanted
to see what entities the is web
annotations end point was able
to find.  The first one I found
was this is a Ford Anglia, which
is the correct kind of car.
And the museum in Singapore
where it's currently on display.
And finally, it was able to
tell me this is from Harry
Potter.  So the way that it does
this, it finds similar images
from across the web, and based
on the context of the pages
where those other images were
found, it's
able to extract these entities.
We also get -- in addition to
the entities, we will get
additional details on the image.
We'll get all the URLs where
the image is found.  This is
useful if you have an app where
users are uploading images and
you want to make sure the image
is  theirs, unique, hasn't been
seen before.  You can use full
matching images to guarantee
that.  Patient matching images,
exactly what it sounds.  It will
give you URLs of visually
similar images.  This is like a
reverse
search.  We might see images of
the car in another context.
And page matching, show the URL
where all the exact image
matches were found.
You can try this in the browser
with your own images.  Go to
cloud.google.com/vision.  Try it
out and see if it's right for
your application before you
start writing code.  And in case
you were  wondering about the
sheep dog versus mop example
from before, this is what the
API returned for the bottom
picture.  It's 99% sure that
it's a dog, and even 77% that
it's a Komondor -- the exact
creed of dog this is.  And able
to identify this as a broom or
tool.  I won't show you the
response for all of them.  But
the API identified three out of
four correctly.  Which is good
considering this model wasn't
trained to specifically identify
pictures of sheep dogs and
mops.  It was able to off almost
all of them correctly.
So that was the
vision API.  Now I want to move
into the speech API, that let's
you implement speech to text
transcription in your
applications in over 110
languages.  One company using
this API  is Azar.  This is a
chat application.  They have
connected over 15 million
matches so far and they're using
the speech API any time an
audio snippet is sent.  They'll
transcribe with the speech API.
And the translation API.  Any
time the two matches don't use
the same language, transcribe is
with the speech API and
translate it into the host
language.
We recently launched a new
feature in the speech API a
couple of weeks ago, speech time
stamps.  So if you specify in
your API request, instead of
just getting the transcription,
you'll get the start and end
time for each word in the
transcription, making it easy to
search for text within your
audio.  So I'm going to go into
a demo shortly of the API.
Briefly, I'm going to explain
how it works.  I wrote a batch
script that's going to call the
speech API.  First it will make
a  recording using SoX, a
command line utility for audio.
Then create an API request in a
JSON file, send it to the
speech API and then receive the
response back.
So let's go to the demo.  Cool.
So the way that I'm going to
call my script is just with
bash.sh.  And I'm going to
record something.  Here we go.
I am super-excited to be in
Krakow, Poland, for Google
Developer Days Europe.  And I'm
going to send that to the API.
While I do that, this is when
the request file looks like.  It
did a pretty good job.  It's
93% confident that it
transcribed it correctly.  I
want to briefly talk about what
the request file looks like.  So
here in how config, we need to
tell the API the encoding type
of our audio using flak, the
sample rate and hertz.  The
language code -- if you leave
this out, defaults to English.
Transcribing in another
language, just specify the
language code you're using.  You
can optionally pass in some
phrases.  If you have proper
nouns specific to the
application that the API may not
recognize normally, you can
give it hints of things to look
for.  We can also give it a
parameter called max
alternatives.  You
notice here we got three
possible transcriptions back.
So you can use max  alternatives
to specify that.  And this then
you can pass your content as an
encoded string or as the URL of
an audio file stored in Google
cloud storage.  That is how the
speech API works.  And I have
one more speech API demo I want
to show you to highlight the
timestamps feature.  Here I have
a video talking about the
Google platform pricing
philosophy.  And below the video
I have a transcription that the
speech API gave back.  Now,
what I can do with timestamps,
is I built a demo that we can
search through the transcript,
essentially.  So if I click on
this, we can skip to the exact
point in our audio where this
occurs.  Is if I go to another
line, you get the idea.  So the
timestamps feature I'm really
excited about.  Because it makes
it easy to search a large
library of video content using
the transcription.  The way that
I did this was that I extracted
the audio from the video and
sent it
to the speech API.
And I have a bunch of videos
about Cloud, Firebase.  So say I
want to search for all my
videos that mention Firebase.  I
can do that here and I can
actually jump to the exact
moment in the video where I see
Firebase.  This video is a
screen cast tutorial about
Firebase Hosting, and we can see
all the points that mention
Firebase.  Which is pretty cool.
In this video, we've only got
one mention of Firebase.  So if
our job was to look through the
video and find all the mentions
of Firebase, chances are we
might miss it.  But with the
speech API's timestamp feature,
we're able to jump right to that
point in the video.
So that's an example of the
timestamps feature of the speech
API.  We can go back to the
slides now.  So with the speech
API you can transcribe audio.
Once you have that text
transcription, the next thing
you might want to do is extract
more data from it.  And that's
where the natural language API
comes into play.  So with the
natural language API, you can
extract entities, sentiment, and
syntax from your text.  One
company that's using it is
Wotric.  And they're a customer
feedback platform.  So what they
enabled customers to do, if you
look at the box in the top
right, the customers place these
feedback forms in many various
places throughout the
application and ask how is the
experience on a speck page from
zero to ten.  They rate the
experience with open-ended
feedback.  And Wootric's job is
to make sense of the feedback.
It's easy to make sense of the
numbered feedback, but it's
difficult with the open-ended
text.  They're using all three
of the natural language API to
do
this.  Entity and syntax
annotation to extract the
subject and see how people are
talking about different topics.
And sentiment analysis to
gauge, did the number scored
line up with the open-ended
feedback that they gave?  And so
this enabled them to do things
like say they have a high
priority customer who is angry
about usability.  They can route
it.  And they are able to route
and respond in near real-time,
instead of having people
manually go through each
open-ended response.  I want to
talk about each of the three
methods of the natural language
API.  The first is extracting
entities.  I have a Harry Potter
example again.  I took a
sentence about J.K. Rowling from
her Wikipedia page and I wanted
to find what was in the
example.  I got these five back.
And looking  closely at the
JSON response it gave for each
one.
So it notice these are three
different ways of referring to
J.K. Rowling.  The third one is
a pen name for a different
series.  That's a topic for
another talk.  But all point to
her Wikipedia page.  It's able
to normalize the mentions of the
same thing.  In our JSON
response we get back the name,
the type of entity -- she's a
person.  And the metadata, and
maps to her knowledge graph.
And then the Wikipedia
URL for her.  And similarly,
maps to the United Kingdom.  It
would have mapped to the same
entity ID.  And a similar one
for Harry Potter.  And if you
have entities that don't have a
Wikipedia page associated with
them, the
API will identify those, just
no metadata.  If it said my
name, the metadata would be
empty because I don't have a
Wikipedia page.  Not yet at
least.
And analyze sentiment.  This
might be on a restaurant review.
The food was terrible.  I will
not be going back.  If I was a
manager of the restaurant, I
want to flag and respond.  I
don't want to go through all the
reviews.  But I can get data on
the sentiment of the text.  Two
values.  The first is score.
And score will tell us on a
negative one to one, how
positive or negative?  And
magnitude tells us, regardless
of positive or negative, how
strong is it?  This is zero to
infinity normalized to the
length of the text.  Since this
is short, we get a small number
of .9.  And then the last method
of the API  is analyzing
syntax.  Gives us more
linguistic details on the
content of the text.  Here we
have the language, the natural
language API helps us understand
text.  The first is a
dependency graph.  This is a
dependency parse tree that tells
us how the different words
relate to each other.  This is
one of the pieces of data we get
back.  And we get the parse
label, which tells us the role
of each word in the seasons.
Helps is the root word, API  is
the nominal subject.  Tells us
the word of each word.  And part
of speech.  Tells us an
adjective, a verb, a pro noun.
And then Lemma, the canonical
form of the verb.  And here, the
helps, con noncal form is help.
And when you are are counting
how many times they happen, you
don't want to count helps and
help as two separate mentions,
they're one word.  So you would
use the canonical way to do
that.  And then morphology in
the text.  This is going to be
different depending on which
language you send to the API.
This is a visualization of all
the JSON you get back.  You can
create your own if you go to the
natural language products page.
There's a try it in the
browser.  You can enter your own
text -- I'll share a link --
you can enter your own text and
share the  visualizations as
well.  So now a demo know
focused on the syntax end point
how to use that in an
application.  I
have been running some natural
language processing on Tweets
using the #GDD Europe.  And I
called a node script with the
Twitter  streaming APU and
looking for Tweets with that
hashtag.  It won't give me all
the Tweets, but it will give me
a subset of Tweets.  And I take
the Tweets and take the text and
send that through to the
natural language API for
processing and store in big
query.  That's Google cloud
platform's big data as a service
tool.  It lets you analyze
really large data sets
super-fast.
So let's switch to a demo.
There we go.  Okay.  So this is
the big query web UI.  It lets
me look at the big data query
directly in the browser.  I
have the schema for my table.
So I'm storing the ID of each
Tweet, the text of each Tweet,
when it was created, how many
followers the user has, the
hashtags as a JSON string which
I get from the Twitter API, and
then the score and magnitude.
So we can preview this.  Looks
like we have collected about 840
Tweets, which is small for big
query.  Big query is for lots of
data.  This is a demo.  We have
the text of the Tweets, the
tags, and then the giant string
of the response.  And we write
our query strings in SQL.  How
am I going to parse this giant
JSON string with SQL?  The
answer is big query has user
defined functions.  Allows you
to write custom JavaScript
functions to parse different
columns in the table.  Here I'm
going to find what adjectives
people are using when they use
GDDeurope.  And I
look for each token, and if the
part of speech is adjective, I'm
going to do a running count.
So I'm running this query and
look at the results.  Pretty
positive attitude about GDD
Europe.  This is good.  These
are the most commonly used right
now.  Again, what's really cool
about this is this is on all
840 of our Tweets and really
fast.  3.1 seconds.  Ran the
custom query on all the Tweets
in the table.  Which is cool.
One more query for you.  I am a
fan of emojis.  Which are they
using most frequently?  It looks
like the laughing crying is a
popular one, clapping, Firebase.
Overall not too many.  Maybe
people should use more in their
Tweets.  But the goal is to show
what you can do with the syntax
endpoint of the with natural
language API.  To see the
sentiment around a particular
topic.  So that's the demo.  We
can go back to the slides now.
So another thing you might want
to do with  text, in addition to
analyze it or transcribe it, is
translate it into many
languages to support all the
users in your application.  The
translation API lets you
translate text in over 100
languages.  Before we get into
it, I want to look at Google
translate.  Anyone else here use
it?  I'm a big fan.  Especially
when I travel somewhere where
English isn't the first language
.  I was in Japan and really
wanted to order okta poppas.
Found out the word was taco, I
was confused.  But go with it.
So I showed it to the waiter and
I got octopus back.  So Google
translate success.  But you want
to do more with Google
translate than translate the
word for  octopus.  And it
exposes all the functionality of
Google translate to developers.
One company that's using the
translation API  is Airbnb.  60%
of the bookings are connecting
people that use the app in
different languages.  And
they're using the translation
API not only
to translate listings, but also
reviews and conversations.  And
they found that using the
translation API significantly
improves a guest's likelihood to
book.
Here is a Python example of how
you would call the translation
API using the Google Cloud
module for Python.  And notice
here that we just passed in the
string of the text we would like
to translate and the target
text language.  We don't need to
tell it the source language.
The API can detect that for us.
And if you also just want to
use the API to detect the
language of text.  So there's
inputting text in a variety of
languages, you can use the
detect language endpoint to do
that.  So we get our translation
result.  Pretty straightforward
.  One improvement we made to
the API was an improvement to
the model call the neural
machine translation.  The way
that the model worked before
with first generation
translation, it would take each
word in the sentence and
translate it word for word.
This is similar to what you
might do if you were traveling
and had a dictionary and had a
sentence to translate and did a
lookup.  You would probably get
your idea across, but
it wouldn't be perfect.  And
what neural machine translation
does is it takes the context of
the surrounding words around
each word in a sentence and it's
able to produce much higher
quality translations.  There's a
great article about it.  Bit.
ly/nyt-ai-awakening picture.
And to highlight the
differences, I have a Harry
Potter example again.  There's a
lot of text on the slide.  I'll
explain it.  Is the original
Spanish translation.  So Harry
Potter was translated into over
70 languages.  Didn't use a
translation API.  Wouldn't have
worked well.  They had somebody
translating the text for each
one.  This is the original
Spanish translation.  And into
English in the first generation
in the middle and the improved
neural machine translation on
the right.  I have bolded some
of the differences.  You can see
these are small improvements,
but they make a big difference
in terms of the overall quality
of the translation.
So that is the translation API.
And the last  API I want to
share with all of you is the
video intelligence API.  This is
our newest machine  learning
API on Google Cloud Platform.
It lets you understand your
video's entities at shot, frame,
or video level.  One company
using it is Cantemo.  They're a
media asset management company.
Their users have tons of
content uploaded into the system
.  And they're using the video
API to help users better search
large libraries of video.
The best way to see how the
video API works is through a
demo.  And so the demo I'm going
to show you here is what I've
got is a video of a Super Bowl
commercial for Google Home.  And
I'm going to play the video.
And you'll notice that it starts
with a mountain pass.  Goes to
a house.  A cityscape.  Lots of
scenes changing in the video.
Now we see a dog.  I won't play
the whole thing.  But you get
the idea.  Lots of scene changes
in the video.  And if you were
to manually transcribe what's
happening, watch the whole
thing, watch what's happening
and store the tags in database
somewhere.  And with video API,
it essentially does all of that
for you.  So the JSON response
tells you at a high level what
is  happening, what the video is
about, and in a granular level,
what is happening in each scene
of the video.  So if we look
below this, we can see the
examples.  It knew there was a
dog in the video and exactly
when that dog appeared.  It knew
that it  ended with birthday
cake.  And if we scroll down, we
can see it identified -- even
the type of dog that we have
there.  And it's also able to
identify that mountain pass from
the beginning scene.
So that's pretty cool.  And this
is just one video.  So chances
are, if you want to analyze
videos, probably got a lot of
videos sitting around in storage
buckets.  And the video API
with the JSON response you get
back, it makes it really easy to
search a large library of
videos.  So if you look here,
I've got lots of videos.  Let's
say I'm a sports media company
and I have lots of sports
footage and I want to create a
highlight reel just of one
specific type of content.  Say I
want to create a highlight reel
of all my baseball clips in my
videos.  So without the video
API, I would have to have
somebody manually watching the
video to find baseball.  This is
easy with the API.  I search
baseball, I get back not only
which videos have baseball, but
we can see all the scenes with
baseball in them.  So this video
is almost entirely about
baseball.
I like this example here.  We
have a long video and there's
one tiny baseball clip in the
video.  So here we have the year
in search video which Google
publishes at the end of every
year highlighting top searches.
And skip here, we can see that
baseball clip.  It's actually
when the Cubs won the World
Series last year.  I was excited
about that.  So if somebody's
job was to scan for that clip,
chances are they might miss it.
It's only one or two seconds of
the video.  But with video API,
it's easy to make the library
searchable.  One more search.
I'm going to search for beach
because it might be nice to be
on a beach today.  It's a little
cold today.  A little rainy.
Can't go to a beach, but search
for beach videos.  Next best
thing.  Here we can find the
beach clips in all of our
videos.  Which is pretty cool.
So something that used to take
hours, now with the video
intelligence API you can do in
seconds or minutes.
Let's go back to the slides.  So
just briefly, I want to share
how the demo works because it
uses a couple of other Google
Cloud Platform products as well.
All the videos are stored in a
Google Cloud storage bucket,
and I have a cloud function
listening on the bucket.  That
is triggered every time a new
video is added.  Make sure it's
a video file, and if it is, send
it to the video API for
processing.  And you can pass in
the parameters the storage
bucket where you would like to
write the annotations to.  Once
it's done annotating the  video,
you can write to a separate
bucket.  And NodeJS, and running
on app engine.  It's not
calling the video directly.
It's getting the video from one
cloud storage bucket and the
associated metadata from
another.  This is what the
response looks like for label
detection.  Here we have a video
with a scene of bird's eye
view.  And the location data.
The start and end time in
microseconds that it occurred in
the video.  If it
occurred more than once, I would
have more than one in the
response.  And a confidence
score.  How confident is it that
it correctly labeled the scene
of our
video?
So that's all I've got for the
APIs.  I encourage you to try
them all out in the browser.  As
I mentioned for the vision API
in the browser, you can
do that for all the APIs
.  Your text, video, try it out,
see the API response.  If you
want the code for most of the
demos I showed today, it's
available in the two repos
listed there.  I'll let you all
get a picture of that slide real
quick.
And thank you.  Thanks for
having me.
[ Applause ]
If you have feedback, I would
love to hear it.  So just go to
this link or follow the QR code
to fill out a feedback form.
Thank you.
>> Hello everyone. Can you hear
me?  I'm Dan Galpin, and Lisa
Wray and I will be giving you a
tour of the latest support
library updates.  We have so
much to cover.  I'm going to
jump into it.  Up with of the
biggest changes in O is we added
adaptive launch
icons.  You saw they were using
custom launchers with custom
icons, and Android shapes and
sayses were all random.  They
would shrink or run with a color
or shape.  We can do something
better than this.  What we did
was create adaptive icon to
enable this type of
customization, you app provides
icons in two layers.  Background
and foreground.  So if the OEM
finds a rounded rectangle, they
will see this.  And circular
shape, like this.  This is cool.
Goes every way in the UI over
the title bar and in the shared
sheet dialogue.  So to support
wider ranges of icon sizes, not
every is the same size as you
have noticed, bigger than  48DP,
we recommend that apps contain
an icon asset of 72DP in size.
So if
they want to render icons in
60DB, it will not be
super-sampled.  The actual size
of the foreground and background
layer that we want apps to
upgrade to is 108DP.  We
recommend that both the
foreground and background are
padded with 25% extra image
around each side.  We want to
use it to add delightful an
makeses such as pulsing.  And
this is just an example -- no,
we haven't added this -- but
someday we might.  You can now
control how your brand is going
to look no matter what icon
shape you choose while
integrating into the visual
design.  This is important.
This is what we have done, added
the adaptive icon class to Oreo
.  And has one  drawable
attribute.  And to help this out
, we added this fractional inset
value.
And this means your inset can
now be density variant, which is
really, really cool.  So as it
turns out, 18 over 8 is 16%.  So
if you use this value to pad
your 72DP launcher icon, there
will be no size increase from a
non-adaptive icon that's big
enough.  But better yet, the
really cool thing is because
these are only in O, Android N,
the vectorial drawable came
expressive enough to have the
vector icons.  Which is really
cool.  So once again, O made a
bunch of critical changes to
other areas too.  Not just
adaptive icons.
They could only block for
spending a Spamming notification
.  We increased notification
channels, and they have the same
behavior and user cans control
them.  And the user can click
here and see the categories.
The category reveals per
-category like vibration and
sound, et cetera.  And we added
dots to the  launcher.  A low
stress way to see if apps have
notifications.  And pressing the
icon reveals the notification.
And widgets installed easy so
people don't have to stress and
figure out how to install them.
And the stuff that was per
notification is on the channel
now.  This is cool.  You can set
the stuff on a channel.  Okay.
I have a bullet point slide,
sorry.  Seriously, don't
overwhelm your user with
channels.  Make them make sense,
give reasonable defaults.  And
you can use notification to set
channels.  And if you're using
Oreo, your notifications are not
going to show up.  App
widgets.  Way back in Android
7.1, we added nifty launcher
shortcuts, and they could pin to
the  launcher and apps could
request it's pinned.  But there
was no indication to the app
that it worked, and the user
wasn't notified that it was
happening, which wasn't great
for users or developers.  It
doesn't work anymore if you're
targeting O.  We now have the
new way with shortcut manager.
It has an  API and takes the
same shortcut
info, and the  launcher asks
the user whether to use it and
where to place it.  And the app
can update the shortcut icon
later with this as well.  And
custom shortcuts were also in 7
.1.  Allowed shortcuts to be
added from the widget tray with
an optional configuration
screen.  And the Oreo API  is
improved there.  You can put the
activity with the filter.  And
in 7.1, return the shortcut as
intent extras directly to the
activity return.  Which is okay.
But now wrap the
functionality, allowing the app
to update the shortcut.  Again,
making the launch better.  And
this has been a really long time
coming.
But we actually have a way for
you to surface your app widgets
in your app.  Like that you no
longer to have beg the user to
find it in the  launcher.  You
can say, I have an app widget,
please install it on your
behalf.  Get prompted and added
to the home screen.  It's
awesome.  I can't believe it
took us this long.  Let's talk
about autofill.  Apps
automatically work with
autofill, but you can do a
better job by providing hints.
And you can mark fields for
autofill to ignore.  You can
also integrate it more deeply.
You can request autofill in your
app.  And you can use autofill
on completely custom views such
as those with open GL or Vulcan.
And no matter how you build
your apps, you should consider
doing this.  And this is kind of
cool.  You have a Website --
the Google autofill provider can
actually share credential
information between the web and
the app if you create a digital
asset link.  This is pretty
straightforward.  You have to
put something on your server.
Some JSON here.  That allows you
to say you want to share login
credentials between the Website
and the app.  And modify the
manifest with a string that
points to a similar JSON
resource that has a list of web
permissions just like on the
Website.  And that's  it.  Two
steps, pair for the Website.  It
works for autofill and also the
first step to implementing
smart lock.  This lets
your users automatically log in
.  If you don't want to go all
the way to smart lock, you can
use this.
And we added cool StrictMode
behavior.  This is great.  It
can detect unbuffered I/O.  And
VM policy allows you to detect
untagged sockets as well as
whens a content
URI  is not, the calling app is
not granting permission.  It's
not useful.  And seeker file
disrupters are for providers.
You can use this for large audio
and video files.  Another thing
we did was added proper support
for caching.  So the quota can
change depending how frequently
the user actually interacts with
the app.  And the amount  used
-- and the amount used.  Well,
the allocate actually takes, you
know, deletable cache into
account.  So pretty slick.  And
there's tons more stuff in O.
I'm not going through it all
here.  Most of you have seen a
lot of this stuff.  But
enhancements to accessibility,
including the ability for users
to add an accessibility button
with soft navigation.  Paging
and content providers.  Great
stuff to make it run faster like
a current copy collector and
changes in media.  But
let's get into the support
library.  You know what I'm
going to say here, devices with
SDK's less than 14 are less than
1% of the the users.  So we
have updated the library and
gotten rud of these guys.  So we
are focusing on what most
developers are targeting.  The
newer version is 14.  And Google
Play services also  recently
dropped this support in version
10.2.  You can use an older
version of the support library
if you want to really target
that.  And dropping AI 14,
benefits, and there is more to
go in later versions.  Our
public API surface reduced by 30
classes of methods.  And what
we need to do now is you can
still use a lot of these things
are AR, but you can start
getting rid of the deprecated
stuff because we're actually
going to get rid of it to even
make things smaller.  And using
the
Google Maven on Android Studio
2.3.  And using plugins, you can
say -- this is kind of sweet.
Text and fonts.  One of my
favorite things.  I love fonts.
In the old
world -- how many did custom
fonts on their Android app?  A
lot of you.  You had to load
type face into the constructer,
and use the custom text view
everywhere.  Yeah.  But now you
have resource type with single
font files as well as families.
And font files get a resource
ID.  And you can make the
families, which are groups of
fonts together.  You can say I
want normal to be this font, and
bold to be this font, et
cetera.  Very, very sweet.  This
webpack generates bar.font.
myfont.  And the textview is
used, and it can handle families
.  The same thing you have been
using all the time.  Both
textile attributes as well as
style spans are supported, which
is really great.  And you can
define them in styles as usual.
Use in code by resources.  And
most importantly, it's imported
on API 14 and above in the
support library.  So go out
there and use more fonts.  And
the only problem is that fonts
bloat the size of your app.  So
we had to think about this.  The
top 25 fonts in Google
fonts actually average 500
kilobytes or more.  And not
optimized for mobile.  How do we
fix this?  Of course we added
downloadable fonts.  And the
font provider fetches and serves
to the apps so you don't have
to bundle them anymore.  This is
cool because the font provider
is shared between apps.  Gives
you memory, framework had, space
savings.  And with Google Play
services and Google fonts you
get over  800 fonts.  So it's
really nice.  And you code, you
can request the fonts using a
font request.  It's like
authority and package and certs
for security and callbacks for
success or failure now exist.
And then you -- and, of course,
you just use
fontscontractcompat.  Don't use
on a UI thread.  And you can
throw them into XML.  It's ease
to use.  It's a string array.
And it actually is pretty  cool.
So we have done full
integration with Android Studio.
We have boring text in the
layout.  A beautiful selection
of fonts.  I'm going to search
for unwith.  There we are.
yesteryear.  It's going to show
up and add the beautiful file
to the  project.  Pretty sweet.
Check out the sample app, and
the guide on Googledeveloper.com
for more info.  And it's all
supported in API 14 plus.  So
nothing worse when someone sends
a message, get a box, no
information.  It's time to get
rid of this  because -- and this
is there because the system has
always bundled the emoji.  And
they are adding new, and it's
hard to keep up unless we can
make it show up.  So the support
library has access to the new
font and checks for glyph if it
it can be rendered
.  The download just happens to
integrate with downloadable
fonts.  Add the dependencies,
make the font request and
initialize on your application.
Very simple.  You don't have to
bundle the emoji font with your
app.  You can.  Targeting non
-GMS devices, you can do that.
Adds about 7 megabytes.  In a
similar way with bundling the
emoji config.  Very
straightforward.  Again, you
have to use these emoji text
views.  You can use emoji text
and button instead of edit text
and button.  But you have to
integrate it in yourself.  We
supply these to help you out.
And now, tacos and unicorns both
exist.  Important things for us
to get across.  So check out
the sample.  More information.
Now, one caveat  here, we didn't
actually backport this all the
way to Kit Kat.  This does
require API 19 plus.  That's the
one minor caveat.  You'll get
to fu on older devices.
Textview autosizing.  How many
have built their own textview
autosizer?  Yes.  I have been
wanting this feature forever.
It text resizes to fill in its
container.  I can't tell you how
excited I was that we built
this thing.  Use the autosize
text type uniform.  And you can
either use an array of preset
sizes or values.  Or min and max
size.  It's easy.  And again,
to API 14 plus.  We brought
improvements to vectordrawible.
If it looks like this in
Android Studio, and shove this
in.  Might be what you get
before.  You get weird
artifacts.  We're using them on
fill rules.  It's a big TBD in
the source code if you went and
looked.  So it  fill-rule
defines
which are inside and outside.
And we added support for this
which you actually fixed finally
in
24.  Back dated to 14 plus.  It
mean yours vectors are more
likely to work.  You know how
awesome this is that we finally
fixed it.  We also did --
imported the stuff from animated
drawable for data morphing.
This is cool.  That is an
example of shape shafter to
generate compatible images with
matching path formats.  And
what's going on at the  XML
level.  The startling image,
buffalo, extract the data.  And
go to elephant.  String
resources and then an object
animater.  And it's more of a
buffalo to a hippo.  And once
again, tie it all together in an
mated vector XML.  We can do
stuff with bundle  XML formats
to make this even cleaner.  So,
again, we can actually use an
element here and it inlines the
flow from the buffalo drawable
and do the same with the
animation attribute.  We have a
bundle that includes the entire
vector drawable animation which
is really cool.  We
have a patent -- once again,
parody.  This is complicated.
We can take a simple example and
show how it works.  It wants to
shrink a square, but have an
interesting acceleration curve.
Use the path interpolater.
This is cool.  Make the can
curve that drops off quickly.
It slowly tapers off.  The morph
animation, and set the
interpolater to be our path
interpolater.  And we can bundle
and this results in this cool,
slightly more cool animation.
Still just a rectangle.
Okay.  Final thing I'm going to
talk about is transition support
library.  So if you've noticed
that we actually added some
transition type in
lollipop and above, available
in the transition library.  You
have to have the dash, dash,
node as an option.  And after
that, you can use all the same
transition XMLs for platform
transition API on 14 and above.
I'm talking so fast, I want the
collaborator.  The star of the
show.  I'm the opening act.
Welcome Lisa Wray who is going
to talk about some amazing
animation --
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you. So I only have
one thing to talk about.  That's
physics-based animations.  So
we have known for a long time
that motion is important in
material design.  Natural
movement inspired by  forces in
the real world.  And I've tried
-- I really have -- but it
hasn't always been easy.  So the
support library has now
introduced two  physics-based
animation.  Not approximations
of motion, but motion based on
natural forces.  Could you have
done this before?  Maybe, but
wouldn't have been easy.  These
ideas are now central to the way
we can animate.  My hope is to
make this type of motion easy
for you think about and easy for
you to use in your app.  Some
things that are easy now that
were hard before.  Responding to
user interaction by which I
just mean a touch.  Chaining
animations.  Modifying them on
the fly.  Getting great natural
movement with much less visual
jank.  So I'm going to step
through the mechanics of the two
dynamic animations we have
right now, and then we'll mix it
up.  So the first, a fling
animation.  Starts with an
initial velocity
, slows down and ends gradually.
So every time that color
changes, it's starting a new
fling.
And here is the simplest fling
that you can make.  Ball is a
view.  Translation Y is the
property we're changing.  And
it's velocity is  pixels per
second.  I discovered while
making this, the pixels are a
lot smaller than I thought.
Everything else is default.  You
can customize a fling by the
factor which it slows down.  So
here's an example of friction.
So from left, you have high
friction to low friction on the
right.  So the less friction
that you have, the more distance
your view will travel for a
given velocity.
And here's a string animation.
And it looks just like what we'd
imagine from the motion of a
physical spring.  It's the force
back to the end point of the
spring.  And you can even get a
bounce.  So every time the color
changes, that is a new spring
animation.  And here's the
simplest spring you can possibly
make.  Ball is a view.
Translation Y is the property
we're changing.  And zero is
where it's going to stop which
is its final translation at
equilibrium.  And its velocity
is pixels per second.  And
everything else is defaults and
it just goes.
So to customize this, you can
call get spring on your
animation, and that gives you
the internal spring force object
.  And that has a damping ratio,
a stuffness, and you can set
the final position.  Damping is
the ratio by which the size of
your bounce is reduced over
time.  And the default is medium
bouncy.  In general the lower
the number, the more oscillation
you'll see.  AKA, bouncing.
Before the force is going to
reach equilibrium.  At one, you
get critical damping, which
means no bounce.  And at zero,
no damping, infinite bounce.
Don't do that.  In general,
please do not underdamp your
views.  This crazy bouncing is
what made me think at first, why
on earth would you want to do
this to a view?  Try little or
no bounce and you'll be
surprised how useful this
animation can be.
Stiffness is like the stiffness
of a physical spring.  So for a
given velocity, how far will it
travel from the endpoint and how
fast will be pulled back?  This
example has no bounce so that
you can see the difference in
the stiffness better.  The
lowest stiffness is on the left,
so it's traveling further.  The
highest stiffness is on the
right.  And you can also create
your own external spring force
in order to share among multiple
animations.  We'll see why you
might want to do that in a
moment.
So one thing you might want to
do with these animations is
allow user input.  So velocity
tracker is one option to handle
this.  It's an oldy, but a
goody.  This class has been
around since API-1.  It does
what it says on the tin.  It
tracks velocity from a user's
touch.  You can also use
gesturedetector if you only hear
what the end state of the fling
is because the fling callback
has velocity.  So how do you use
this?  We're going with vasty
tracker for now.  Use it on the
touch listener of the parent of
the view you want to track.
Parent is the word.  Call
Velocity tracker, obtained.  And
feed in the user's touch events
starting with down and
continuing with move.
Then in action up, you'll call
compute current velocity, and it
will compute a nice velocity
for you.  After you are done,
make sure to clear it.  It's X
and Y.  Then you're going to
start two dynamic animations at
the same time, one for the X
velocity and one for the Y
velocity.  They're going to run
simultaneously.  And as you can
see, this is enough.  This gives
you a smoothly moving interact
iive two dimensional
interaction.  And you can see it
works pretty well.  Be careful
when you fling.  They do not
automatically stay on the
screen, and when they're gone,
they do not come back.
Just like other animations
you're familiar  with, dynamic
animation has end and update.
That's how I was changing them
in the earlier demonstration and
changing the ball colors to
repeat over and over again.  So
let's change to fling
animations.  We're going to
fling, just as we did before,
using the velocity from our drag
listener and velocity  tracker.
And create one for X and one
for Y to get natural movement.
Then we're going to stop the
first animation at the edge and
create a new one in a different
direction, giving the impression
the ball has bounced.  This
time, add an update and end
listener to the updates.  And we
will check to see if it's
slipped out of the bounds of
its parents.  There's probably a
better way to do this, but
that's an exercise for the
reader.  If it did go outside,
we'll cancel the animation.
We'll get a callback to on
animation end.  If we cancel it,
meaning it hit the edge, then
fling it back.  I made an
extension on View
here.  We'll use the velocity
past here, which is the
remanuallying velocity from the
canceled animation.  And we'll
use it in the opposite direction
, which is the minus sign you'll
see there.  Of course, it's not
exactly this simple.  What this
does is it flings the ball
straight back at you because it
reverses both of its velocities
-- X and Y.  So what we really
want is natural reflection.  We
want it to only reverse its
velocity on one axis and
continue on the other.  And that
will give us the 90 degree
bounce angle.  So it's not too
hard.  It looks like this.  If
it's hitting the horizontal
edge, reverse X.  Otherwise,
reverse Y.  And we get a nice
reflection, or bounce.  And it
also works with different
animations.
Ever seen something like this?
There's an app that keeps trying
to do this on my home screen.
I don't know why I'm encouraging
you to do this.  It's
interesting because it's quite
simple.  It's sort of a sticky
effect.  Fling to the edge and
it absorbs the momentum with the
bounce.  It's going to do
something like this.  The thing
to note is we're  using the
ball's current translation value
as the end value for the spring
.  So we're going to fling as
before with an end listener.
And then when we get the
callback, go ahead and oscillate
until you reach equilibrium.
Dissipating the remaining
velocity.
Chaining springs.  There was a
cool demo in the Google I/O talk
I went to of three springs.  If
you want to look that up, do.
I'm not going to talk about
it here.  This is inspired by a
screen in the plaid app by Nick
Butcher -- sorry, Nick.  They
translate up, one after another.
In that fact, the distance
translated, the delay of each
element and the interpolation
used to accelerate are all
hard-coded by hand.  That's a
pain in the butt.  Here, it's
all done with the same chained
spring we just saw with the
balls.  I'll go through how that
works.  So what's actually
going on here?  These two
springs are almost exactly the
same effect.  Obviously, the top
ball -- the blue ball -- is the
lead.  The yellow ball follows
it.  And the green ball follows
the yellow ball.  Almost as if
they're chained together with
bouncy springs.
In the actual app example, the
lead view is the headline and
icons.  The next view, the
paragraphs, follow it.  And
finally the tab is following the
paragraphs.  There's no rule
that these views actually have
to be in a line in terms of
position.  They can be anywhere.
What matters is the
propagation of effects from one
animation to the next.  So how
do I do this?  Instead of a
touchlistener, I started with a
fixed sprung animation on the
headline.  Instead of a
velocity, I gave a start value.
Basically I said pull the
spring back this far and start
it there.  And I gave it an
update listener, which we have
seen before.  Then I made a
spring animation for the
paragraphs.  Exact same thing.
In the listener, getting
callbacks from the headline, I
call animate to final position
on the paragraph animation.
This is a really important and
useful method.  So it's going to
do two things.  One, it sets
the new final position of the
paragraph spring to the current
position of the headline
animation.  And two, it starts
the paragraph animation if it
hasn't yet.
And finally, do the same thing
for the fab.  Start an update
listener on the paragraphs and
chain a spring animation to
that.  And that's how chaining
works.  The difference here from
what we were doing before with
flings is they were subsequent,
one after another.  These are
happening simultaneously.  You
might notice, if you were
looking closely, I  used the
spring on the outside of the
views and the scale of the fab.
So what else can you animate?
You can animate a lot of
built-in properties.  Certainly
everything I can think of
flinging or springing off the
top of my head.  You can animate
alpha, translation, scroll,
scale, and X, Y, and Z, absolute
positions, including
transition.  If you want to make
a custom property that groups a
couple of these, make an
instance of
floatpropertycompat.  And set
the minimum range so it doesn't
animate tiny bits forever.  And
start every animation at a start
value and give a minimum and
maximum.  And
finally, quits the
animations.  If they stop, it
will crash.  These are available
from Jellybean and above.  I'm
sure you got all of that.  If
you didn't, the code is on my
GitHub, Lisawray/fizz
Wray/physics-playground.
They're way more than bouncing
balls, they're a great way to
bring interaction to your
current UI.  So I look forward
to seeing what you make with
them.  Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Thank you so much.
>> Hi, everyone. I'm Tom. I'm
one of the technical leads in
the VR and AR efforts in Google.
We specialize in developer
productivity tools.  I'm excited
just a week after announcing
ARCore to talk to you about the
ARCore
SDK preview and how you can add
AR capabilities to your Android
apps.  So just a quick run
through of what we're going to
talk about today.  So we're
going to talk about AR and it's
closely related cousin, VR.
We're going to talk about the
concepts that underpin ARCore.
A walk through the API.  We're
going to talk through all the
options that we have to build
our AR content.  And talk about
the options for
for building your code as well.
So before we get into the
technical details, I really want
to start with what immersive
computing means.  Where we've
come from and what can it do for
you?  I'm always asked why AR
and VR?  We have mobile devices.
It's great.  Why should we do
these other things?  So with
card board, daydream and tango,
we have been investing for quite
some time.  And we believe that
interacting with data in a more
natural way is the future.  And
immersive computing removes the
distractions between you and
your computing.  So I want to
take a minute discussing these
technologies before we jump into
some code.
So we think of AR and VR as
being points on a spectrum of
immersive computing.  On the far
left, reality, the world as we
know it that we're in  today.
If it we start to add digital
content into our reality, then
we start to augment it.  Hence,
augmented reality.  And if we
completely replace that reality
with a virtual, we have virtual
reality.  And so AR can bring
any of your digital content to
you and in your world.  Such as
this guy posing with the dog.
So some of the benefits of AR,
you can see objects at real size
and scale in your world.
Imagine being able to buy
furniture and being able to see
if it actually fits in your
house before you buy it?
You can also see things in
context.  Again, imagine buying
that furniture and making sure
that it matches with all the
other decorating in your house.
And imagine being able to
annotate the real
world.  Like post it notes
without causing a real physical
mess.  And also has the ability
for natural input for 3D scenes.
If you have used digital
creation and content tools, it's
hard to control that camera in
your scene.  With augmented
reality, you hold your phone and
just look at it.  And anyone
can do it.
And then if you replace
everything in your world with
the virtual -- with digital
content -- you have virtual
reality.  It allows you to go to
places and visit worlds in an
instant.  And some benefits of
this are you get complete
immersion.  You really feel like
you have been transported to
another place.  And there's some
really, really huge innovations
in input that really lets you
work naturally in your world.
Both VR and AR enable us to
experience computing more like
we experience the real world.
And both take advantage of a lot
of the same technologies.
So back in 2014 we started with
the idea that your devices
should be able to understand
more of the world.  So with
dedicated hardware, tango
allowed us to understand the
depth and build great
applications from being able to
measure your world.  Being able
to map and share your house.
And to be able to play some
games on your table top with
your friends.  We built two
consumer devices with Asys and
Lenovo and created over a
hundred applications for tango.
And you we can do more with
software than three years ago
and don't have to rely on custom
sensors.  And leads us to last
week's announce want with ARCore
.  Last week we announced
ARCore.  It's a preview SDK to
get up and running.  We're
building applications right now.
It takes everything from tango
and makes it available on the
phone you have today, no cameras
or sensors required
required.  It's in development,
and we want to get your
feedback to make this work for
you.
And with 2 billion devices out
there, we have a huge potential
audience for this technology.
With ARCore so far running on
the pixel, pixel XL and the
galaxy S8 we run on millions.
And working with Samsung, Asi
and others.  So we anticipate we
are going to run on 100 million
devices.  And we're working
with the hardware vendors to
make this possible with a really
consistent bar for quality and
high performance in the same way
that we did with Daydream.
Before getting into the code,
it's important to understand
some of the fundamental concepts
behind AR so you know how AR is
working under the hood.
So there are three main concepts
to think  about.  One is motion
tracking.  Two is environmental
understanding.  And three is
light estimation.  So let's go
through them in a little bit of
detail now.  So to render AR
content, you need a virtual
camera that matches your
physical camera.  You render the
virtual scene, you compose it
with your camera and you're
done.  This sounds simple.  It's
actually really, really hard.
Your phone gyro scope is great
for rotation, it can drift over
time.  And the axel ROMer is
great for instantaneous inputs,
not so good for actual position.
The hard part of getting AR
right is figuring out the
translation and rotation of the
device in real time so you can
render digital  objects with the
same virtual camera as your
physical camera.  If you get
this wrong, objects in the world
are
misaligned with the virtual
components and won't appear
properly rooted in the world.
And you can see how effective we
have done this
ARCore with the scare crow that
looks like everyone else
queuing for tacos.  To do this,
we look the at camera and the
inertia using concurrent come
try and mapping.  COM.  It
tracks over successive rings and
builds up the point cloud to
localize against that point
cloud.  This, combined with the
high-frequency INU gives you
rotation and translation in the
world to render your virtual
content in exactly the right
place.  This is over and above
other experiences you may have
tried which only uses the
gyroscope to get the rotation
which has the problem of content
sliding around your world and
you can't move in closer for a
better look.  This is key for
creating digital content of the
real world.  So this
illustration is an example of
the device tracking feature
points in your world that create
a cloud.  When it does it for
real.
So motion tracking, really
important.  Environmental
understanding is also
super-important.  Rendering
content isn't actually that
interesting by itself.  You need
to be able to interact with
your world as well.  So ARCore
is looking for clusters of those
feature points that appear to
lie on common, horizontal
surfaces and makes the surfaces
available to your app as planes.
Since planes are
mathematically infinite, ARCore
provides the bounds of the
surfaces as a polygon.  And you
can place objects in your world
like this Android guy here.
So planes are detected on
horizontal
surfaces such as the floor,
tables, kitchen countertops,
benches, chairs, you name it.
However, because ARCore uses
feature points to detect these
surfaces, flat surfaces without
any texture or
highly-reflective surfaces might
not be detected properly.
And then finally, light
estimation.  So ARCore is able
to detect information about the
current environment's lighting
and gives you a valuable
representing that given
intensity of the camera image.
This lets you light your scene
of the virtual objects under the
same conditions of the
environment which increases that
sense of realism.  If you don't
do this, your digital objects
will stand out and not appear to
be a part that have world,
which is really, really key to
realistic rendering.  And some
really fun effects, like you
have a lion who gets scared when
you turn out the lights.
And it might seem frivolous, but
it's actually really important.
If you've ever taken your
camera and just
looked at a light source or
pointed out the window, the
autoexposure of the camera
changes that range hugely.  It
can be really not so great it
you don't take this into
account.
So now we've gone through the
main concepts of ARCore.  Let's
jump into code and see what it
takes to build an AR application
in Java.  So this is how I
think of the API.  You create a
session which represents the AR
session you're running.  Once
you have this, you update the
session and you have a frame.
Once you have a frame, that
represents your camera
and the metadata that goes
alongside that.  You create
planes.  Once you have planes,
you're able to create anchors.
With anchors, you can place
content in your real world.  And
the hello
AR app is on GitHub and it's
great to work with this.  So
going through the code, it's
really, raylets to start an
ARCore session.  Just start a
session.  We provide a default
configuration file which
basically turns on every part of
the API.  Motion tracking,
plane finding, light estimation.
A simple way to check if your
device does not support ARCore.
And when we come to render our
application, first thing we do
is clear the frame.
And then we simply call
session.update.  One of the key
concepts to understand here is,
when you created your session,
one of the things you might want
to change within your config is
whether it's using blocking or
latest camera image.  If it uses
blocking, it basically gives
you a frame at the rate at which
your camera runs.  Which kind
of makes sense.  You don't want
to render any faster than you
have to.  You want to make sure
that every pose aligns with
every frame.  But for some of
your applications where you want
a really smooth update, you
have animations, you might just
want to render as fast as you
can and at the expense of power
and performance.
So once you have a frame, we
have this helper function.  Hit
test.  Which helps us do custom
array into the world based on a
touch location and see if you
have touched one of these
planes.  If it  collided and the
tap was within the bounds of
that detected plane, go into the
anchor.  And we'll go into
anchors more later.  We have to
see if the frame was actually
tracking.  You know, if you put
your hand in front of the camera
or something and you're not
tracking, you want to make sure
that your intersections are
correct.
And then you query the frame for
all the data that you need to
render your objects.  And don't
worry if you haven't used
projection matrices before and
you don't know from a view
matrix is.  That's okay.  As
mentioned earlier, to render
this AR content, you have to
match the field of view of your
virtual camera with the field of
view of the real camera.  The
projection matrix has all the
properties you need and take the
ARCore session to get access to
those.  And in this example we
set the range of objects that
you'll render from 10
centimeters to 100 meters.  And
then the view matrix is what
contains out information from
motion  tracking.  That contains
the pose of where the camera is
in the world.  And finally,
getting access to the lighting
estimation.  Just a simple call.
Once you have that value, you
can either use it for some
logic, or use it to affect your
rendering and your lighting.
And then finally, we loop over
all of our  an cores we have
placed in the world.  And if
they're being tracked, we render
those objects.  So if the
projection matrix contain the
camera  properties and the view
matrix contains the camera
location, the model matrix
contains the location of that
anchor within the world.  And
with the combined model view
projection matrix, you can put
pixels on the screen and
properly overlay on top of your
camera feed.
So talking about anchors, why do
we need  anchor?  What is this
concept of an anchor?  You might
think, it's three-dimensional
space.  Why not call it the
origin and place your objects
relative to that?  So it turns
out there's actually some error
in the poses you get back from
motion  tracking.  Motion
tracking is constantly updating
its understanding of the world.
And if you use anchors, as
this understanding of the world
updates, the pose of your models
will update as well.  A good
example where you want to use
anchors is, imagine walking
around a building in a loop.
When you get back to where you
started, that drift will have
accumulated over time and you
want to use anchors to make sure
that all stays correct.
And so if you place an anchor in
the world, you should make sure
you place the digital object on
top
of that anchor as well.  Any
time there's error in the
rotation, the further away from
the anchor, you will end up with
a lever arm effect where you're
pivoting around the center of
the object and it's translated
off from where it wants to be.
And think about these anchors
are there to root your digital
objects -- your physical objects
-- in the world.  If I was
going to place an object on a
chair, I want to create one
anchor for the chair, place the
object on the chair.  Ten
objects on my desk, I don't need
to create ten anchors.  Just
create one and place them all
relative to it.  Again, avoid
the global coordinate systems.
You'll have a bad time if you
use those.
So we kind of skipped over this.
Apart from clearing the
screen, we didn't really talk
about rendering 3D.  Rendering
3D is actually a really big
topic that I couldn't possibly
cover in a 30-minute talk here
today.  But to give you
something to look at, there are
a few options.  You can use open
GL/ES directly.  And we have
great tutorials to get  started
on developer.android.com.  Or
frameworks such as Rajawali that
does a lot of the heavy
lifting.  Or look at our sample
which contains model rendering
code if you want to place some
objects in had your world.
So not only does ARCore work
with Java, it also works with
Unity and Unreal.  And we have
done a lot of work to make sure
it integrates really well.
Common game engines like these,
they remove a lot of the
complexity from managing a
complex 3D scene so you can
actually focus on actually
building your application.  So
weave ported helloAR into Unity.
You can see it there.  It
exercises all of those same
APIs.  And we have designed it
so you can  easily get up to
speed, use those scripts and
prefabs in your own application
and it becomes part of the SDK
when you download it.
And similarly, the same for
Unreal as well.  We have done
everything to make building your
AR applications really easy
using the tools that you're most
familiar with.
So another option is WebbXR.  So
real web standards for AR don't
exist yet.  But these
prototypes allow web developers
to start building augmented
reality web experiences today.
Their experiments will teach us
all what AR on the web will look
like.  And hopefully make the
design standards faster and
better designed.  These are
built on top of web VR.  If
you're familiar with that, it's
easy to get up and running with
WebXR.  And this demo also works
in experimental versions of
Chrome for AR kit as well on iOS
.
And so we've talked a lot about
building AR applications, but
the really hard part is, how do
I get content?  We all know how
to create content for 2D.  We
know how to get images.  We know
how to get text, fonts, videos.
We know how to create them and
we know how to use them in our
applications.  So Google have
been working in AR and VR for
quite some time.  We've made
creating this content really,
really easy.  Which is why we
created blocks.  So blocks let's
you build 3D content in VR
really  quickly.  And even if
you don't have a VR head sed,
take a look at the library.  Any
content is available for
download.  So let's take a quick
look at some of the content
that our creators have built
from blocks.  So if you want
this guy,
are a men chef in your kitchen,
is that is available to you.
And if you want this guy to
watch over you at night on your
bedside table, you can live that
dream.  It's really impressive
what people have made using
blocks.
It's a super easy way to get 3D
content in your application.
Led head to our blocks Website,
download it and give it a play.
It's really, really fun
building in VR.  Before we
finish, I would love to give you
a taste of some of the things
that we built in ARCore.
[ Applause ]
So this has been a whirlwind
tour of the capabilities of
ARCore.  And all the information
you need to get started is
there today on our Website.  So
we've talked about the
fundamentals of AR, we've talked
about the options you have to
build your AR applications, and
we've talked about how to build
content for those applications.
With actively  seeking feedback
from developers such as
yourselves through this phase.
And monitoring GitHub and other
channels closely so we're
building a platform that works
for what you want to build.  You
can see the  AR next big shift
in what's possible for the
mobile devices.  Get started
with the ARCore today.  We
really can't wait to see what
you've built.  Thank you.
[ Applause ]